MEDIA ON GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
WILL COME TO ORDER I'M GONNA
EXERCISE THE PRIVILEGE OF THE
CHAIR FOR- JUST A COUPLE OF
MINUTES TO WELCOME YOU TO ONE OF
THE NEW HEARING ROOMS- WE HAD
OUR INAUGURAL BAPTISM OF THIS
ROOM A COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO AND I
WAS SO NERVOUS I FORGOT. TO
INTRODUCE MYSELF AS THE NEW
CHAIR SO- MY NAME IS ANA COME
OUT YET- AND I'M VERY HONORED TO
BE CARRYING THIS- GREAT
COMMITTEE AND ALSO I DIDN'T I.
SERIOUS ERROR THIS IS LIKE A
FULL PINE THE SENATE I FOR GOT
TO THANK MY THE FORMER CHAIR UP
MIKE MCGUIRE WHO DID AN
OUTSTANDING STELLAR JOB VIA OF
LEADING THE COMMITTEE AND WE
THANK HIM FOR HIS GUIDANCE AND
HIS- HIS HARD WORK AND- AND HE
LEADS ME BIG SHOES TO FILL SO I
WANTED TO MAKE SURE I SAID THAT-
AND- AND I'M NOT QUITE SO
NERVOUS THAT. IT'S THE NEW THIS
THE NEW ROOM IS- ROOMS TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED IN THE- STREET
BUILDING AND- AND IF THEY'VE
DONE IT AT A REALLY GOOD JOB IN
THIS IS. THIS IS THE ROOM WILL
<c.green>E USING- UNTIL THE NEW- SPACES</c>
CREATED IN THE CAPITAL SO THAT
WE CAN MOVE BACK THERE SO. THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US HERE TODAY
SO- GOOD AFTERNOON IN RESPONSE
TO THE COVERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY
IN TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS. TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. TO ALLOW PUBLIC ACCESS
WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE HEARING ROOM TO
THE TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT WE WELCOME YOUR
PARTICIPATION TO THE TOLL FREE-
AN AXE CODE IS PO. ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
877-226-8163 AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS SEVEN SIX TWO TWO FOUR SIX
TWO. FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW THE TELECONFERENCES TO
MARKS PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE
OR THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN
WE MOVED MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU WILL BE PROMPTED BY A
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO
FOR SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION. S.
THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT. ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU
WILL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LNE
NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU WILL BE
FINE MUTED AND YOU ARE NOW READY
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE SO YOU
CAN JUST START. SPEAKING NOTE
THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DESTRUCTIVE DISRUPTIVE. MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE FOR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED AND I'VE GOT
TO SAY THAT I'VE NEVER HAD TO DO
THAT. SO I DON'T EXPECT TO HAVE
TO DO IT TODAY. WE NOW. HAVE
TWELVE BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA
WITH NO ITEMS PROPOSED FOR
CONSENT. ITEM NUMBER THREE SB
THIRTEEN FORTY FOUR BY SENATOR
RUBIO WAS PULLED FROM THE AGENDA
BY THE AUTHOR AND WILL NOT BE
HEARD TODAY. BEFORE WE HEAR
PRESENTATIONS ON THE BILL'S LIST
LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
. SENATOR CABALLERO HERE
CABALLERO HERE SENATOR NIELSEN
NIELSEN HERE SENATOR DORADO
DORADO HERE SENATOR HERTZBERG
HERE HERTZBERG HERE SENATOR
WIENER. WIENER PRESIDENT. YEAH
AKORN HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED NOW
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM OUR
FIRST AUTHOR I WANT TO WELCOME
SENATOR GLAZERS AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE GLAD YOU'RE
HERE TODAY YOU MAY PRESENT YOUR
BILL SB EIGHT FORTY THREE. GOOD
MORNING AT. FIRST LET ME SAY HOW
PLEASE STAND TO BE JOINED BY MY
JOINT AUTHORS SENATORS DRAWS SO
IN OUR PRESENTATIONS WARNING. I
WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR THE
COMMITTEE FOR ALL THEIR WORK ON
THIS BILL. ALSO WANT TO THANK
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WHO
MANY OF WHOM ARE CO AUTHORS OF
THIS LEGISLATION. THE RENTER'S
TAX CREDIT WAS ESTABLISHED IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO. ONLY
INCREASED ONCE AND THAT WAS IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE. MORE THAN
FORTY YEARS AGO. SINCE THEN THE
AVERAGE RENTS IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
MORE THAN TRIPLED. SUPPORTING
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
RENTERS HAVE BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED BY
THE ECONOMIC CONSEQUENCES OF IT
NINETEEN. RUNNERS ON AVERAGE OR
LESS THAN HOMEOWNERS AND FOR
MORE AT RISK OF LOSING THEIR
JOBS BECAUSE OF THE STAY AT HOME
ORDERS. THIS BILL. WOULD NOT
THAT DIFFERENTIATE BETWEEN
SINGLE FILE FILERS WITH
DEPENDENTS AND JOINT FILES
THAT'S A BIG CHANGE IN OUR
CURRENT LAW TODAY. WOULD PROVIDE
A THOUSAND DOLLAR CREDIT FOR
SINGLES WITH DEPENDENTS AND
THOSE JOINT FILERS. IT ALSO
PROVIDE A FIVE HUNDRED DOLLAR
CREDIT FOR ALL OTHER SINGLES. I
WOULD ALSO MAKE THE RENTER'S TAX
CREDIT REFUNDABLE. MEANING EVEN
THOSE WITHOUT A TAX OBLIGATION
COULD CLAIM THE CREDIT. AND ALL
OVER SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND
RANCHERS WHO NOW RECEIVE LITTLE
OR NO CREDIT. BECOME NEWLY
ELIGIBLE ACCORDING TO THE-
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD ESTIMATES.
THE SMART PROGRESSIVE BILL
COMPLIMENTS CALIFORNIA'S LONG
TERM GOAL TO INCREASE AND EXPAND
ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
WHAT WILL TAKE YEARS TO ENSURE
THAT CALIFORNIANS COULD HAVE
ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE HOMES THIS
BILL WILL HELP MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS. OUT QUITE QUICKLY.
THE BILL IS LONG OVERDUE AS I
MENTIONED HAD BEEN CHANGED IN
FORTY TWO YEARS OLD A PROVIDE
RELIEF TO TWO POINT FOUR MILLION
LOW AND MIDDLE INCOME RENTERS.
AND LYFT PLEASED AS I SAID TO BE
JOINED FIRE JOINT AUTHOR AND
FOLLOWING THAT DAVID KNIGHT FROM
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY ACTION
PARTNERSHIP ASSOCIATIONS HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
SENATOR- AND GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WANT TO
THANK THE- SENATOR FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD- THIS IS A
REALLY IMPORTANT WAY TO PROVIDE
RELIEF WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
THE RELIEF THAT. RENTERS NEED
THE HIGH COST OF RENT FACING
EVICTIONS ARE IN MY DISTRICT
ALONE THERE ARE NEARLY A QUARTER
OF A MILLION. RENTER HOUSEHOLDS.
THAT IS 77% OF ALL HOUSEHOLDS.
IN THE DISTRICT WE HAVE THE
HIGHEST NUMBER OF RENTERS IN THE
STATE. THIS IS NOT A SOLUTION BY
ITSELF BUT IT WILL BRING
IMMEDIATE IMPACT TO THOSE MANY
MANY FAMILIES WHO ARE BOTH IN
THE LOW. AND IN THE MIDDLE
INCOME COMMUNITIES THEY ARE
STRUGGLING EVERY DAY WITH
SKYROCKETING COSTS OF RENT. SO
IT IS MY PRIVILEGE AND I'M VERY
PROUD OF A TO A JOINT AUTHORED
THIS LEGISLATION I URGE AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR I'D LIKE
NOW TO CALL ON. LEAD WITNESS
DAVID KNIGHT TO PRESENT IN
PERSON THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
. THE MORNING I THINK DOLLAR
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COMMITTEE ACTION PARTNERSHIP
ASSOCIATION NO WE ARE NONPROFIT
MEMBERSHIP ORGANIZATION IS
COMPRISED OF THE IXTY COMMUNITY
ACTION AGENCIES AND COMMUNITY
SERVICEBLOCK GRANT ELIGIBLE
AGENCIES THROUGHOUT ALL FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES. HERE IN
CALIFORNIA THE EACH AGENCY WE
REPRESENT CREATES LOCALLY
DEVELOP SOLUTIONS AND
OPPORTUNITIES AS WELL AS
MINISTERS CRITICAL FUNDING AND
SERVICES TO HELP ECONOMICALLY
DISADVANTAGED CALIFORNIANS IN
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES TO
MAINTAIN STABILITY AND CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES SELF SUFFICIENCY.
ON BEHALF ACCOUNTABLE TO
DIRECTORS AND AGENCIES I'M HERE
TO TESTIFY FOR SUPPORT OF SB
EIGHT FORTY THREE AUTHORIZED A
SENATORS STEVE GLAZER AND CO
AUTHORED BY OVER FIFTY
LEGISLATORS WHICH INCLUDES
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND INCLUDES
ALL FIVE MEMBERS IS COMMITTEE.
CENTER. DRAWS OF JUST SAID. WE
UNDERSTAND SERVICE PERCENT
HARDEST. RENOUNCING WE CAN SEE
WHAT IS PORT. SAID HERTZBERG WE
WHERE FEET PERCENT OF YOUR FOR.
THE PERSON I JUST OUT ON MONDAY
THAT I WOULD BE RECEIVING A PER
RATING HERE IN SECOND. NOW WHAT
IS BILL IS NOT TARGET FROM
DIRECTLY IT DOES SHOW ALL RIGHT
FOR AND TO REALLY. HIS APPARENT
. CAL CAMPER MEMBERS BUT FOR
HEAVILY ON TREATING THE- FOR ALL
CAL. THAT THE ABILITY PROSPER
THEIR OWN TO MAKE. CENTERS
GLAZER MEASURES A MAJOR STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION EACH FAN
WITH IT WE START. YELLING WILL
TAKE YEARS SAID MEET THE GOALS
OF ETHICAL THIS. THE REDDIT
THREAD ARE STRUGGLING TODAY.
THIS CREDIT WILL GIVE UP. TO RUN
THE VERGE OF. INTO IS A REAL. SO
FOR TO. WHILE ENSURING LAW TERM
CARE. FOR THE- NOW HERE I AM
TODAY. FOR YOU MARKET JUST A
MOMENT TO THE SENATE- PASSED A-
TWENTY SEVENTEEN. WHICH IS YOU
KNOW WAS A RENTER'S. MOTOREN.
WHICH LIKELY WILL. EVEN MORE
READY FOR. REMAIN MAINLY REMOVED
FROM THEIR- THIS IS A C. THAT
RAN A RELEASE THEM IS A HUGE
FROM. IN THIS. IN CONCLUSION
EIGHT. SAID SB EIGHT THREES ONLY
UP SMALL PUBLIC POLICY. BUT NOW
IS THE TIME TO USE. AS MENTIONED
PERCENT GLAZER HOME. OR SEE FIVE
POINT EIGHT BILL TAX FEATURE.
WHILE RENTERS ARE PREVIOUSLY
ONLY. ONE TWO. WHICH SINGLE TO
THE MAJORITY OR OVER. TWO PER OF
. WHO IT. THEY SHOULD BE
REQUIRED TO HAVE YOUR POOR. OF
OUR NEW WILL BE. VALUE TO
NURSES. THEREFORE DURING SUCH A
TIME OF NEED FOR ANY FAN NOW.
THE TIME WE GIVEN. THE FAIR.
AMERICA NOW I WANT TO THANK
SENATOR. FOR HIM TO. ADDED ON
BEHALF. OF THE PASSAGE OF SB
EIGHT FORTY THREE. IF ALICIA
THIS. RICK THE SUPPORT. THIS
BILL CREATES. FOR OUR FAMILIES
AND FOR ALLOWING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY ON
BEHALF ACCOUNTABLE DIRECTORS.
OURMEMBERSHIP IN THE
COMMUNITIES WE SERVE THANK YOU
VERY. MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR BEING HERE. SO NOW WE'RE
GONNA. MOVE ON TO AN- WHO WANTS
TO TEST. IN SUPPORT. YOU TOO%
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE LENGTH
OF HEARINGS. TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS. COMMITTEE CHAIRS MAY
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY. EACH SIDE WILL BE
PERMITTED IN AN EQUAL AMOUNT OF
TIME. TO BE DETERMINED BY THE
CHAIR. ALL OTHER SWITCHING TO
TESTIFY MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURES. WE'VE HAD- ONE. WELL
LAUT LET'S BEGIN WITH WITNESSES
HERE IN ROOM. TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
THAT ARE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS RANDY MARTIN
ON BEHALF OF THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION AND ITS HOUSING IS A
HUMAN RIGHT DIVISION AND VERY
STRONG SUPPORTER OF THIS LONG
OVERDUE BILL THANK YOU VERY-MUCH. THANK YOU IS THERE ANYBODY
ELSE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. THING THEN WE'LL
MOVE ON TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS. MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
SB EIGHT FORTY THREE WE WILL WE
CAN REFER BEGIN. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT FORTY
THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. ONE AND THEN ZERO GUARD
THE PARTS OF AT THE. EIGHT FOUR
THREE. AND WE WILL GO TO LIVE IN
FORTY THREE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE FORTY THREE
LINEUP OPENS. I'M HERE FOR A
DIFFERENT. OKAY THANK YOU. AND
WE WILL MOVE ON TO LINE THE
FORTY ONE YEAR LIGHTED UP THEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE MORNING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS KAREN LAYING
ON WE OFFER THEN THE JACK COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND THE
CITY OF SANTA MONICA BOTH IN
SUPPORT THIS MORNING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. MEXICO CAROLINA THIRTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MODEL AND COOKBOOK COOPER FROM
THE OPEN MARKET MURDER ON BEHALF
OF THE LAKE COUNTY CONTRA COSTA
IN SUPPORT IN HILL. THANK YOU.
NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU FOR LIKE
THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR DECLINED
CALIFORNIA CITIZENS. THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU OVER LINE
THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING THIS REBEKAH
DOLLARS FOR THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU
MEXICO LINE TWENTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I TWENTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN TO HAVE A FUN YOU.
HELLO WE CAN HEAR YOU. FIVE THIS
IS ALBERT FORTY AND THAT I'M A
RESIDENT- AND REGISTER SO WE ARE
CURRENTLY SUPPORT OF THIS THAT
MEASURE- WE ALSO ASK THAT THAT
THAT THAT POSSIBLY YOU COULD NOT
LOOK AT THE RENT CONTROL BUT
THAT THAT'S ANOTHER WE'RE ONE
STEP AWAY FROM- FROM
HOMELESSNESS SO WHAT THE
PREVIOUS OWNER AND- NOW
UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE RENTING
STUFF- WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE AND THANK YOU FOR THAT
IN THE CLUB OR FESTIVAL THAT I
IT'S. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TED. NOW PLEASE. THANK YOU
HAVE A LINE FIFTY HERE LINE IF
OPEN. FIVE HI DURING AND I'VE
GOT A HARD COPY ON BECAUSE- BE
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXT PLEASE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE NO FOR
THE IMPORTANT AT THE STATE. VERY
GOOD. NOW WE'D LIKE TO MOVE TO
OPPOSITE IS ANY THAT LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION IT'S IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED. SEEING NO
ONE MOVING. MADAME MODERATOR IF
YOU COULD- ADVISE THAT WE'RE
MOVING ON TO OPPOSITION AND ASK
ANYBODY THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFIED TO PLEASE- JOIN THE
CALL. PRESSING ONE INTERVIEW IN
OPPOSITION. IN OPPOSITION OF SB
EIGHT FOUR THREE MY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT IT ONE AND
THEN ZERO IN OPPOSITION OF THE
F. B. EIGHT FORTY THREE. AND
MEDICARE WE HAVE NO OPPOSITION A
QUEUE AT THIS TIME VERY GOOD.
WILL BRING THE MATTER BACK TO
THE- COMMITTEE IS ANYBODY HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS CONCERNS. MOTION
YES CENTER WIENER OKAY I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR BOTH AUTHORS
AND BASICALLY CENTER GLAZER FOR
DOGGEDLY. PURSUING THIS- HE BOTH
CAME IN THE- LEGISLATURE- YOU
KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF. HE'S MADE
TALK RIGHT NOW- ABOUT PUTTING
MORE MONEY AND CALIFORNIANS
POCKETS AS PEOPLE. THOSE
INVESTMENTS AND I THINK- PUTTING
MONEY INTO THE POCKETS OF
RENTERS WHO WERE STRUGGLING TO
PAY RENT- IS A GOOD FOCUSED WAY
TO DO IT SO I'M OF THE BILL.
MOTIONS BEEN- THE MOTION IS- IS
TO MOVE THE BILL AND THEN IT
WOULD WILL BE REFERRED- ANY
OTHER COMMENTS IF NOT I WON A
SECOND THAT AND SAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT
MEASURE AND ALLOW YOU TO CLOSE-
I ALSO WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
VERY MUCH FOR AS YOU SAID
SENATOR. DOGGEDLY JUST.
PERSISTENT PERSISTENT. ANALYSTS
SAY- FOR ME IT'S NOT ONLY
HELPING THOSE WHO COULD BE
FACING HOMELESSNESS FACING BEAN
AND UP ON THE STREET. BUT IT'S
GIVING STABILITY TO THOSE
FAMILIES TO BE ABLE TO BECOME
HOMEOWNERS- AND THAT STABILITY
WHEN YOU HAVE THAT OVER A
CERTAINLY A NUMBER OF YEARS. YOU
COULD ACTUALLY END UP BUYING A
HOME SO FOR ALL THOSE REASONS I
OUT- ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SENATOR KIRBY AUTO I
CABALLERO HI SENATOR NIELSEN AYE
NIELSEN AYE SENATOR DORADO.
DORADO HI SENATOR HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG FIVE SENATOR WIENER
AYE WIENER HI. OVER THE MOTION
PASSES. FIVE TWO ZERO. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER TWO ON OUR GENDER WHICH
IS S. B. EIGHT SIXTY BY SENATOR
RUBIO. WELCOME. I THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TODAY I AM PROUD TO
PRESENT SB EIGHT SIXTY WHICH
WILL PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE TO LOW
INCOME FAMILIES CHRIS I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING SO
HARD WITH ME AND ALL
STAKEHOLDERS FOR THEIR INPUT ON
THIS BILL AS WE KNOW CHILD
POVERTY CAN HAVE A DETRIMENTAL
IMPACT ON OUR YOUNG CHILDREN I
HAVE WITNESSED FIRST HAND. THIS
IN THE CLASSROOM ACCORDING TO
RECENT REPORTS 50% OF OUR
FAMILIES WITH CHILDREN UNDER SIX
IN CALIFORNIA ARE STRUGGLING
FINANCIALLY AND THAT'S OVER
THREE POINT FIVE MILLION
FAMILIES CURRENT CURRENTLY DO
NOT EARN SUFFICIENT INCOME TO
MEET THEIR BASIC NEEDS I
REMEMBER AS A TEACHER MANY TIMES
HAVING TO FEED THESE CHILDREN
THAT WOULD COME INTO MY
CLASSROOM I WOULD HAVE SNACKS
BECAUSE I ALWAYS KNEW WHICH ONES
NEEDED TO BE FAT WHO HAD ONLY
HAD ONE MEAL THE DAY BEFORE. I
REMEMBER SOME OF MY FAMILY
SLEEPING IN CARS. AND DESPITE
THAT STILL DOING EVERYTHING THEY
POSSIBLY COULD TO ENSURE THAT
THEIR CHILDREN. RECEIVED A GOOD
EDUCATION. THIS BILL WILL
PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED RELIEF TO
THOSE LOW INCOME FAMILIES
STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT THERE IS
A CORRELATION BETWEEN A CHILD'S
ECONOMIC STATUS AND THEIR
ACADEMIC PERFORMANCE. THIS CASH
ASSISTANCE WILL MAKE A HUGE
DIFFERENCE IN THE LIFE OF THOSE
FAMILIES. THE CURRENT INCOME
ELIGIBILITY THRESHOLD IS SET AT
ONE DOLLAR HOWEVER THIS BILL
WILL ENSURE THAT THE Y. C. T. C.
IS INCLUSIVE TO IN HOME CARE
GIVERS. WERE WORKING HARD TO
RAISE THEIR CHILDREN I HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE SINCE LAST
YEAR AND I WAS THRILLED TO SEE
GOVERNOR NEWSOM ALSO PRIORITIZES
IN HIS JANUARY BUDGET PROPOSAL.
MADAM TERRIFIED ME I WOULD LIKE
TO INTRODUCE MY WITNESSES THAT
ARE ONLINE TO TESTIFY HERE TODAY
IN SUPPORT AND I HUSTLE BLAD
WITH THE UNITED WAYS OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. I'D LIKE TO- INVITE.
ON A HASSLE BLOOD TO SPEAK SHE
IS ON THE PHONE MADAM. MODERATOR
IF YOU COULD FIND HER AND PUT
HER ON. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
ANA HOW THE LAST WEEK UNITED WAY
THE CALIFORNIA. ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY ATC COALITION AND HELP
POVERTY CALIFORNIA WE ARE THE
CROWD COULD SPONSORS OF SB EIGHT
SIX C. EIGHT SIXTY FOR THE CLEAR
VISION OF INCLUSION FOR ALL LOW
INCOME FAMILIES WITH YOUNG
CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH
TAX CREDIT. THE YOUNG CHILD TAX
CREDIT AND FEDERAL COUNTERPART
THE CHILD TAX CREDIT. THE TRACK
RECORD OF PROVEN POVERTY
REDUCTION WITH THE TTC ALONE
LOOKING ROUGHLY THREE MILLION
CHILDREN OUT OF POVERTY JUST
THIS YEAR. IN CALIFORNIA THE
YOUNG TECH HAS A- REDUCED AND
MORE THAN IN FAMILIES OF WHO ARE
. UNFORTUNATE FAMILY WITH NO
EARNED INCOME ARE NOT CURRENTLY
ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE THIS CREDIT
HOWEVER LOWERING THE THRESHOLD
TO ZERO DOLLARS WOULD ENSURE
THAT THE Y. SI PC IS INCLUSIVE
OF. IN HOME CARE GIVERS WITHOUT
PAPERWORK ARE WORKING HARD TO
RAISE THE CHILDREN. CALIFORNIA
SHOULD INCLUDE THE FAMILY WIFE
P. C. AS A WAY TO RECOGNIZE THE
UNPAID CAREGIVING WORK. OF
WORKING PARENTS. WHAT THEY YOU
UNDERVALUE PULL AND BENEFITS OUR
ENTIRE SOCIETY IN FACT EACH YEAR
IN THE US OVER FOUR MILLION
FAMILY CAREGIVERS PROVIDE THIRTY
SEVEN BILLION HOURS OF CARE
WORK. FOUR HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
BILLION DOLLARS THE YOUNG
CHILDREN PARENTS ABOUT THE AND
OTHER LOVED ONES. THE CLEAR THIS
IS CLARK. UNPAID AND ON FOR WORK
BUT CRITICAL AND DEEPLY VALUABLE
AT THE ALL. THE SAME. FOR THE
RECORD FOR. RECENT NON. LEARNING
TO RECOMMEND. IT SHOWS A LOT OF
NOT. PREVENT CALL FROM FILING
FOLDER. FOR NON FILER TO LOOK
FOR ALL. PROCESS TO THE THIRD
TAX CREDIT. NOT MAN AT ALL
REMOVING THE EARNINGS AS
ENVISIONED BY A FEW EIGHT SIXTY
ONE ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF THE
PAST WITH A CLEAN MEETING FOR
TAX CREDITS AND TELL. AND NOW I
WANT TO SHIFT- JUST BRIEFLY
FISHER PERFECT OF AND HER. THE
COMMUNITY IMPACT DIRECTOR UNITED
WAY FOR THE WINE COUNTRY WHO
OVERSEES VOLUNTEER TAX
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM THERE HE
SAYS. I WANT TO VOICE MY FULL
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT SIXTY FIVE
WITNESS FIRSTHAND THE DRAMATIC
DIFFERENCE AND IMPACT THE CHILD
TAX CREDIT AND CHILD TAX CREDIT.
HOW THE LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
MANY FAMILIES SPECIFICALLY WOMEN
WERE FORCED TO LEAVE THE JOB
MARKET. TODAY AT HOME WITH THEIR
YOUNG CHILDREN DURING KOBE. THE
RECENT FIRES HERE IN CINEMA
COUNTY ALSO REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
QUALITY DAY CARE PROVIDERS
MAKING AN ALREADY BAD RESOURCE
PROBLEM WORSE. HAVING BEEN A
SINGLE MOTHER MYSELF IT IS
IMPERATIVE CALIFORNIA HONOR THE
ROLE STATE HOME PARENT AT THE
VITAL JOB IN SOCIETY. AND WE
NEED TO RECOGNIZE AND COULD BE
DONE PAID CARE GIVERS AND THE
YOUNG CHILD TAX CREDIT. TO GIVE
YOU A TASTE OF LOCAL IMPACT I
WOULD TELL YOU ABOUT ONE OF OUR
UNITED WAY CAFE CLIENTS ENJOYED.
HE THE STRUGGLING LOW INCOME
SINGLE MOTHER. OR HERO INCOME IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND WITHOUT
VOLUNTEER ASSISTANCE WITH A BOOK
COMPILED ZERO INCOME TAX RETURN
TO RECEIVE THE FEDERAL CHILD TAX
CREDIT. FOR HER TWO YEAR OLD
TWINS. BUT SHE WOULD NOTHING FOR
THE STATE OF. THIS IS BECAUSE
THERE IS NO. TO THE FEET THINK.
FOR HER. THIRTY BE IN CALIFORNIA
DRAKE COULD RECEIVE THOUSAND PER
. IF UNDER. POUNDS HE WOULD HAVE
HAVE IN IN. TAX PAYMENTS COME
CONTRACT BONTA JOY. HOW HE
SHOULD BE A TO MAP A WORKING TO
EARN AN INCOME UP TO. TWO YEAR
OLD TO. WHILE TRYING TO FIND
AFFORD THERE'S- SYSTEMS. INSTEAD
OF SHOULD REMOVE THE EARNINGS
FOR. THE WIFE THE GIVEN OF ON
THE GO REALITY FACED BY SO MANY
CA. IN HOW. I'VE BEEN IT'S ABOUT
A LOT OFFER OUR- SUPPORT FOR A
FEE SIXTY SENATORS. FRAZIER AYE
VOTE THANK YOU SO MUCH. YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TEST TODAY. NOW I
LIKE TO MOVE TO- AB COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT IN ROOM TO TWO HIGH IS
THERE ANYBODY THAT WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE ART GIVE TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT. THING NINE WE WILL MOVE
ON TO- TESTIMONY FROM THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE MADAM
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD OPEN THE
LINE FOR COMMENT IN SUPPORT SB.
EIGHT SIXTY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT SB EIGHT SIXTY MY PRESS
ONE ZERO. AGAIN THAT ONE AND
THEN ZERO YOU WERE IN SUPPORT OF
SB EIGHT SIXTY. AND WE WILL GO
TO LINE UP THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MY THIRTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THE DALLAS
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT LINE
PLEASE. THANK YOU OVER THE LINE
FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO IS KEVIN IN SCOPE WITH THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
OF CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT PLEASE. IT WILL CUT THE
LINE FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THERE MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THAT
SCARY ONLY WITH ECONOMIC
SECURITY PROJECT ACTION IN
STRONG WORK. THANK YOU. NEXT
PLEASE HE THANK YOU LINE OF
FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IF
YOU MANAGE YOUR WITH GREAT AND
HOW PARTY CALIFORNIA'S STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR WE HAVE NO FOR SUPPORT
QUEUE AT THE FIVE VERY GOOD NEXT
I'D LIKE TO MOVE ON TO
OPPOSITION THERE IS NO SIGNED UP
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYBODY HERE
IN THE ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. SEEING NO
ONE MATTER MODERATOR WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO THE TELECONFERENCE
LINE. YOU MAY REQUEST IF ANYBODY
WANTS TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
SB EIGHT SIXTY. THANK YOU IN A
POSITION OF SB EIGHT SIXTY MY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN
THAT'S ONE AND THEN FIGURE UP IN
OPPOSITION UP AT THE. EIGHT
SIXTY. MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE NOT
POSITIONING QUEUE AT THIS TIME
VERY GOOD I'M GONNA BRING THE
MATTER BACK TO THAT COMMITTEE
FOR COMMENTS. LET ME JUST SAY
THAT I REALLY APPRECIATE THAT-
THE EFFORT YOU PUT INTO THIS
BILL- IT DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE
NOT TO- NOT TO GIVE A CREDIT. TO
PARENTS THAT ARE. HOME TAKING
CARE OF THEIR CHILDREN- AND
ESPECIALLY FOR WITH VERY YOUNG
CHILDREN IT MAKES A LOT OF SENSE
SO I THANK YOU FOR YOUR- YOUR-
YOUR WORK ON THIS BILL NIGHT- I
WILL BE SUPPORTING IT TODAY
SENATOR ISAH- WELL I WOULD MOVE
THE BILL BUT I JUST HAVE ONE
QUESTION SEAN FOR THE AUTHOR. DO
YOU HAVE ANY A GUESSTIMATE OF
HOW MANY FAMILIES- THIS WILL.
HELP BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY IT'S SUCH
AN IMPORTANT- OF. BILL BUT JUST
WONDERING IF THERE'S A
GUESSTIMATE AND NOW WE DON'T
HAVE A NUMBER AT THIS WOULD HELP
APPROXIMATELY FIFTY FIVE
THOUSAND ADDITIONAL FAMILIES
THEY WOULD BE RECEIVING THE
SUPPORT. THANK THERE IS A
MOTION- WILL ALLOW YOU TO
CONCLUDE CENTER RUBIO THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS-
WE MUST AND DO BETTER HEARING
CALIFORNIA TO ENSURE THAT WE
TAKE CARE OF THOSE MOST
VULNERABLE AMONG US NOT ONLY FOR
THEM TO BE ABLE TO BE FED AND
HOUSE BUT CLOSE THE POVERTY GAP
AND SO WITH THAT I WANNA THANK
MY SPONSORS AND I ASK FOR YOUR
RIFLE. THANK YOU. THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED BUT FIRST BE RE RE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SENATOR CAMBIADO HI
CABALLERO HI SENATOR NIELSEN.
AYE NIELSEN AYE SENATOR DORADO.
DORADO HI SENATOR HERTZBERG BERG
- YOU SENATOR WIENER. BORDER
ZERO THE BILL IS FORTY ZERO WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR SENATOR
WIENER THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATOR. LIKE LIKE TO MOVE
ON TO ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB NINE
SIXTY NINE BY SENATORS LAYERED
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOURS THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- IN JANUARY OF THE
LEGISLATURE MOVED- THE BILL I
HAD TO ESTABLISH A WATSONVILLE-
UP A HOSPITAL DISTRICT IN THE
PAPAROA VALLEY AND WATSONVILLE
IN RECORD TIME IT WENT START TO
FINISH IN UNDER THREE WEEKS AND
IT WAS NECESSARY BECAUSE THE
HOSPITAL WENT INTO BANKRUPTCY.
WELL WAS UP FOR PURCHASE AND
WITHIN DAYS- AFTER THE GOVERNOR
SIGNING THE BILL THE BANKRUPTCY
COURT ACCEPTED THE BID OF THE
DAYS OLD HOSPITAL DISTRICT TO BE
ABLE TO PURCHASE THE HOSPITAL
AND PUT IT IN COMMUNITY
OWNERSHIP AND IT'S IN A PROCESS
IN THE NEXT FEW WEEKS OF DRAWING
UP THE BID AND THEN THERE WOULD
BE OUR- ACTUAL CLOTHES OF.
ESCROW EXCUSE ME AFTER. BECAUSE
BILL MOVED SO QUICKLY OUT OF
NECESSITY THERE WERE THINGS THAT
NORMALLY WOULD BE IN A BILL WORK
- THE GOT THE BORDERS. APPOINT
THE- OUR BOARD MEMBERS AND TELL
AND ALLOW COULD BE HELD. BUT THE
LOCAL AGENCY FORMATION
COMMISSION PROCESS LASKO
NORMALLY THEY DO A SPHERE OF
INFLUENCE STUDY. INTO THERE'S
REGULAR REAP. THE WOULD HAVE
SLOWED DOWN BILL AND SO I PLEDGE
TO DO A FOLLOW UP BILL THAT TOOK
CARE OF THOSE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS- THIS BILL R. S. B.
NINE SIX NINE IS THAT BILL IT
WOULD REQUIRE THE SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY LASKO. TO DEVELOP
INDETERMINACY OF INFLUENCE STUDY
FOR THE HOSPITAL DISTRICT WITHIN
ONE YEAR IN ALSO A DO REPORTS
REPORT REGARDING THE PROVISION
OF HEALTHCARE- BY DECEMBER
TWENTY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY FIVE.
AND EVERY FIVE YEARS AFTER THAT
AND IT WAS AS AN INTERIM
REPORTING REQUIREMENT THE BILL
WOULD REQUIRE THE DISTRICT
ANNUAL REPORT TO THE COMMISSION
REGARDING HEALTH CARE PROVISION
IN THE DISTRICT IN TWENTY TWENTY
THREE AND TWENTY FOUR. DOLLARS
SINCE THE ANALYSIS WAS RELEASED
THE TEAMSTERS AND THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS AND
SUBMITTED LETTERS OF SUPPORT
THERE'S NO REGISTERED
OPPOSITION- THIS JUST CONTINUES
TO FORWARD A MOVEMENT AND I VAST
TO PEOPLE THAT WERE READY TO BE
A WITNESSES AND SUPPORT ONLINE-
TO BE AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS AS
WELL. DO YOU HAVE QUESTIONS IN
THE HOPE THAT WE WOULD MOVE THIS
ALONG WITH THAT- I RESPECTFULLY
ASK. FOR MY PHONE. VERY GOOD. I
THANK YOU MADAM AND JEAN HURST
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
PARKROSE VALLEY HEALTH CARE
DISTRICT PROJECT BOARD OF
DIRECTORS AS WELL AS THE SANTA
CRUZ COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
AND SUPPORT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS SHOULD THE TIME
COME UP. VERY GOOD. THUNDERLORD
I HAVE- MIMI HALL AS THE-
WITNESS THAT WOULD TESTIFY BUT
SHE I'M AT ADVICE SHE'S NOT ON
THE PHONE SHE HAD A CONFLICT IN
IT DEPENDED ON HOW LATE THIS
BILL WENT OKAY AND SO I THINK
GOT MISS HEARST. IS TO
SUBSTITUTE THAT'S GOOD WHY DON'T
I THINK THAT- APPRECIATE YOU
BEING HERE IN PERSON AND I. SHE
BEING AVAILABLE ANYBODY THAT
MIGHT HAVE QUESTIONS ON WHAT
WE'RE GONNA DO IS MOVE ON TO
SUPPORT IS THERE ANYBODY IN
SUPPORT HERE IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED. SEEING NO MOVEMENT WILL
WILL MOVE ON TO SUPPORT ON THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE MADAM
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD ADVISE
THOSE WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. NINE SIX NINE
TWO. TWO PLEASE LET YOU KNOW.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT AT E.
NINETY SIX NINE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT
ONE AND THEN ZERO FEAR IN
SUPPORT OF AB T. NINE SIX NINE.
AND I'M SURE WE HAVE NOTS
PORTANTINO AT THE FIVE VERY GOOD
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYBODY HERE
IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED THAT
WISHES TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL. SEEING NONE WILL MOVE
ON TO THE TELECONFERENCE LINE.
BUT A MODERATOR IS THERE ANYBODY
ON THE TELECONFERENCE LANE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU FOR IN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. NINE SIX
NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. AGAIN THAT THE ONE AND
THEN ZERO IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION OP ED HE. NINE SIX
NINE. AND MEDICARE WE HAVE NO
OPPOSITION IT TIME VERY GOOD
WILL BRING THEM MATTER BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE. ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT. THERE IS A
MOTION TO MOVE THE BILL. CENTER
LARGE THANK YOU FOR YOUR-
DEDICATION TO THIS ISSUE THIS IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT FOR THE
COMMUNITY OF WATSONVILLE AND- AT
THE LITTLE BIT OF THE CART
BEFORE THE HORSE BUT IT WORKED
AND SO- GLAD TO SEE YOU HERE YOU
KNOW COMPLETING THE LAUGHTER
PROCESS WHICH IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT- AT YOUR- A ALLOW YOU
TO CLOSE IF YOU ARE HAVE YOU
JUST HAD A WONDERFUL. CLOTHES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I REQUEST AN
ODDBALL THANK YOU SO MUCH
EMOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
SENATE FLOOR THIS AGAIN WILL BE
ONE OF THE QUICKEST BILLS. TO
PASS THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE
THIS YEAR. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
. SENATOR CAMBIADO. I CABALLERO
HI SENATOR NIELSEN. AYE NIELSEN
AYE SENATOR DORADO. THROUGH ALSO
HI SENATOR HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG
HI SENATOR WIENER. WIENER I.
FIVE ZERO THE BILL IS OUT FIVE
TWO ZERO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
REMOVE ON TO SENATOR NEWMAN.
RIGHT OKAY WILL MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER SIX ON THE AGENDA WHICH
IS SENATOR PORTANTINO'S SB. TEN
SIXTY SEVEN. GO WELCOME CENTER
PORTANTINO THANK YOU A- THANKS
KAREN MEMBERS. I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT S. B. TEN SIXTY SEVEN-
I'D LIKE TO START BY ASKING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS LOCATED-
IN COMMENT FOUR AND FIVE OF THE
NOW ASSISTANT THANK THE
COMMITTEE CHAIR. AND STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH MY STAFF TO
CONTINUE TO IMPROVE- THIS BILL-
PARKING MINIMUMS REQUIRE PRIVATE
PROPERTY OWNERS TO PROVIDE AND
MAINTAIN A CERTAIN NUMBER OF OFF
STREET PARKING THESE MINIMUMS
IMPOSE A FINANCIAL- AND
ENVIRONMENTAL AND SOCIAL COSTS
TO CITIES- SB TEN SIXTY SEVEN
WILL PROHIBIT THE CITY FROM
IMPOSING MINIMUM PARKING
REQUIREMENTS AND A HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT PROJECT IS LOCATED
WITHIN A HALF MILE PUBLIC
TRANSIT AS LONG AS CERTAIN
REQUIREMENTS ARE MET-
ELIMINATING PARKING MINIMUMS
WITH CLOSE PROXIMITY TO PUBLIC
TRANSIT WITH LESSEN CALIFORNIA'S
DEPENDENCE ON CARS PROVIDE MORE
SPACE FOR WALKING AND BICYCLING.
AND HELP COUNTERACT HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY PROBLEMS BY
CUTTING COSTS FOR TENANTS AND
DEVELOPERS- WE HAVE I CAN COME
UP WITH A UNIQUE PROPOSAL TO
CREATE A TWO PRONG STRATEGY TO
ENCOURAGE AFFORDABLE AND
WORKFORCE HOUSING WITH ONE AND
THEN PUT SOME SAFEGUARDS AROUND
JUST TOTALLY- DOING AWAY WITH
PARKING MINIMUMS WITHOUT HAVING
SOME SORT OF- PUBLIC BENEFIT IN
ADDITION TO THE LOWER
CONSTRUCTION COSTS SO. LAST YEAR
I WAS ASKED- TO COME UP WITH AN
ALTERNATIVE AND THIS IS THE
ALTERNATIVE AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE WHEN APPROPRIATE
. VERY GOOD. AND IS THERE
ANYBODY HERE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. THING NINE WILL GO ON
TO THE TELECONFERENCE LINE.
MADAM MODERATOR IF YOU COULD ASK
IF THERE'S ANYONE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB TEN SIXTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF SB
TEN SIXTY SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT
ONE AND THEN THEIR FINANCIAL OF
AT LEAST. TEN SIXTY SEVEN. MADAM
CHAIR WE HAVE NO SUPPORT QUEUE
AT THIS TIME VERY GOOD WILL MOVE
ON TO- ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION IS
THERE ANYBODY HERE IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED IN OPPOSITION
. SEEING NO MOVEMENT WILL MOVE
ON TO THE TELECONFERENCE LINE AT
A MODERATOR IF YOU COULD ASK IF
THERE'S ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK ON SB
TEN SIXTY SEVEN. THANK YOU IF
YOU'RE IN. AT EIGHT TEN SIXTY
SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. GETTING THAT ONE AND THEN
ZERO IF YOU WERE IN OPPOSITION
S. TEN SIXTY SEVEN. AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MODERATOR- MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE JEREMY
SMITH HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE BUILDING. AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL IN RESPECT WHAT
POSITION ARE WE JUST WORRY ABOUT
THE- NUMEROUS ELECTRIC VEHICLE
MANDATE COMING ON THE
LEGISLATURE WILL MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE HAVE A PLACE TO PARK
THEIR CARS IN. AS THE- POLICY OF
MANDATING ELECTRIC VEHICLES-
ESCALATES- OVER THE COMING YEAR
TO AS WE AS WE TRY AND USUAL WAY
FROM- WELL I GUESS. OIL AND GAS
INTERNAL COMBUSTION ENGINE. SO
OFTEN REASONS WE ARE AT RISK LAS
OFICINAS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXT PLEASE THANK YOU
NEXT WILL. NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND
MARIE- DO YOU REPRESENTING THE
LOS ANGELES ORANGE COUNTY'S
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL ALSO A PASADENA RESIDENT
AND CONSTITUENT OF MISTER
PORTANTINO'S AND WE STAND ALSO
IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO BILL ONE
OH. SIX SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT PLEASE THANK
YOU NEXT TO VOTE. THE LINE
FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WATCH
IT. MY FIFTEEN YEAR LINE IS OPEN. PRESIDENT BUSH IS AGENT OF
WORKERS LOCAL STICK. WE ARE
STRONGLY OPPOSE OF GUILT. ONE
ZERO SEVEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. YOU KNOW THE LINE FIFTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. OKOBOJI DELETE ZI
BUILDING TRADE STANDING WITH THE
STATE TRADES NOT POSITION
AGAINST. SEVEN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU OF
THE LINE FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YEAH THIS IS GAP FENDED
OFF WITH THE HUMBOLDT BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES AT A
HUMBOLDT. DEL NORTE COUNTY
STRONGLY OPPOSED THIS BILL WITH
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES. THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE IN THE PROJECT
MEDICARE THERE IS NO OPPOSITION
I THINK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WORLD BEING BRING. BILL BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE COMMENTS YES
CENTER WIENER THANK YOU MONTERO
I FOR SOMEONE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR ENGAGING ON THIS
ISSUE I'VE BEEN- A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF- ENDING- MINIMUM
PARKING REQUIREMENTS- BOTH WHEN
I WAS ON THE BOARD SUPERVISORS-
IN SUPPORTING LEGISLATION LAST
YEAR OR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN. I CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
HER BELL AND I'M GLAD THAT THERE
IS AN I. I THINK THE MORE THE
MERRIER IN THIS CONVERSATION- WE
VERY CLEAR THAT PARKING
MANDATES- ARE ANTI HOUSING- DIED
IS NOT ABOUT ENDING PARKING IN
NEW CONSTRUCTION. PEOPLE WHO
BUILD HOUSING ARE GOING TO WANT
TO HAVE WHATEVER WORKS FOR IT SO
THAT THEY CAN SELL OR RENT OUT-
FIVE HOMES- AND IF NOT HAVING
ANY PARKING IN A PROJECT IS
GOING TO HARM THEIR ABILITY TO
DO THAT THEY'RE GOING TO PUT.
SOME LEVEL OF PARKING AND- BUT
HAVING A ONE SIZE FITS ALL YOU
MUST DO AT LEAST ONE PERSON ONE
PARKING SPOT PER UNIT OR TWO PER
UNITS- REALLY UNDERMINES THAT.
GOAL AND WHAT IT DOES IS A FEW
THINGS. AND WE KNOW FOR INDIAN
I'M GETTING ALICE THAT A REAL
GOOD JOB OF LAYING OUT SOME OF
THE SIGNIFICANT DOWNSIDES. OF
MANDATING PARKING AN OVERSUPPLY
OF PARKING BY INCLUDING MAKING
HOUSING MUCH MORE EXPENSIVE. AND
REDUCING THE AMOUNT OF HOUSING-
THAT YOU- THAT IS DELIVERED
BECAUSE YOU ONLY HAVE SO MANY
SQUARE FEET OF BUILD SOMETHING.
AND IF IT'S MANDATED THAT YOU
MUST DEDICATE A REALLY HIGH
PERCENTAGE. OF THAT SQUARE
FOOTAGE THE PARKING THAT MEANS
FEWER HOMES ARE BEING BILL AND
WE'RE MAKING THAT CHOICE THAT
YOU KNOW A LIVING SPACE FOR A
CAR IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN A
LIVING SPACE FOR HUMAN BEINGS-
SO IT'S LONG PAST DUE THAT WE
MOVE AWAY FROM THIS PARKING-
MINIMUMS AND I APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR. I THINK IT IS I ALSO
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR HAS BEEN
TAKING FEEDBACK AND MAKING.
CHANGES TO THE BILL- AND DOING
THAT ON HIS OWN WITHOUT BEING
FORCED TO DO IT- AND LISTENING-
AND I KNOW THAT THAT WILL
CONTINUE- I. WILL CENTERS OF THE
OPPOSITION- WE HEARD TODAY- YOU
KNOW I THINK THERE ARE YOU KNOW
I'VE BEEN A STRONG SUPPORTER OF
ELECTRIC VEHICLES AND MAKING
SURE THAT PEOPLE CAN PLUG THEM
IN. I WHERE THEY LIVE I DON'T
THINK THAT THAT IS AN ARGUMENT
FOR HAVING MORE PARKING. I KNOW
IT'S AN ARGUMENT FOR WHATEVER
PARKING WE DO HAVE- MAKING SURE
THAT THERE IS A IS ACCESS FOR
ELECTRIC VEHICLES AND IT'S NOT
ONLY FOR GAS VEHICLES. TALKING
TO TWO ISSUES- TO ARE NOT IN
CONFLICT- THIS BILL- WILL BE
COMING TO THE HOUSING COMMITTEE
AS A SECOND REFERRAL AND THE
AUTHOR AND I ARE ALREADY.
PLANNING TO SIT DOWN. I'M GOING
TO SUPPORT MOVING THIS BILL OUT
OF COMMITTEE TODAY WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT OF COURSE I
RESERVE MY RIGHT. GLOBAL WORK
TOGETHER I MEAN WE WILL PROBABLY
HAVE SOME ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS
THAT WILL WORK COLLABORATIVELY
WITH THE AUTHOR- ON BUT- I WILL.
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY AND
I'M. HAPPY TO DO THAT. SENATE
HERTZBERG. YES THANK YOU FOR
MUCH MA'AM YOU KNOW. I LOOKING
AT MY NOTES AND ALSO ON THE AND
NOW HERE OF US TEN SIXTY SEVEN
WITH INTENSITY SO. THE ONLY
OPPOSITION WAS A LIVABLE
CALIFORNIA SOUTH PASADENA
RESIDENTS RESPONSIBLE GROWTH
AND- WELL JUST LISTEN I WANTED
TO. GET SOME SENSE FROM YOU.
MISTER ATIONS CHEER AS TO- ANY
CONVERSATIONS YOU MAY HAVE
UNDERSTANDING THE OPPOSITION
THAT THE BUILDING TRADES BOTH IN
LOS ANGELES AND STATEWIDE HAVE
WITH RESPECT TO THIS BECAUSE I
DON'T HAVE THAT ANYTHING IN MY
NOTES THAT RESPECT. THE IT THEY
DID REACH OUT AND SAY THAT THEY
WERE GOING THEY HAD SOME
CONCERNS AND WE'RE GOING TO
EXPRESS SOME TODAY AND I SAID.
COURSE EXPRESS YOUR CONCERNS AND
YOU KNOW THEY I WAS NOT BLIND
SIDED OF THATCHER. THANK YOU SEE
I JUST DON'T HAVE IT. MY
QUESTION TO YOU IS YOU KNOW
THOSE CONCERNS ARE. WELL I THINK
IT HAS TO DO WITH- GENERAL
CONSTRUCTION CONCERNS I THINK IT
HAS TO DO POTENTIALLY WITH HOW
THEY NEGOTIATE WITH CITIES- I'M
NOT GONNA SPEAK. ON THEIR BEHALF
I MEAN. YOU YOU HEARD THERE THE
EXPRESSION BUT- YES CERTAINLY
I'M GONNA CONTINUE TO TALK TO
THEM AS I TALK TO. EVERYBODY TO
AS THIS HOPEFULLY MOVED OUT OF
COMMITTEE TODAY. WELL I YOU KNOW
. I IN IT MIGHT. IT DID OF LINES
. ME LITTLE TO BE HOW. WITH YOU
I WISH I WOULD'VE KNOWN- I WANT
TO READ THE- ANALYSIS IT WASN'T.
I DON'T WANT TO. STOP YOUR BILL
FROM MOVING. BECAUSE YOU ALWAYS
BEEN. WORKS WITH EVERY BUT IF HE
GETS OUT WITHOUT ME THAT'S
GREAT. DONALD VOTE FORD ON THE
CAN. THAT I WENT TO WORK OUT
THIS WEEK. WITH THE BILL ENTRIES
WITH WHO I KNOW YOU HAVE A
BRILLIANT RELATIONSHIP. THANK
YOU. ANY OTHER COMMENTS THIRTY
DRAW A YES I A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS- ONE THING THAT WE'VE
BEEN GRAPPLING WITH IT IN THE
HOUSING CRISIS IS NOT ONLY MORE
HOUSING MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND I NOTE THAT YOU INCLUDE THAT
HERE I GUESS MY QUESTION IS.
THERE'S TWO OPTIONS ONE IS THAT
IT MUST YOU KNOW IF IT HAS MEETS
A 25% A MINIMUM OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. OR THEN THERE'S THE
OTHER OPTION COULD YOU EXPLAIN
HOW THE TO WORK TOGETHER BECAUSE
I WANT TO END UP WITH MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THAT'S WHERE
WE HAVE OF. THE GREATEST CRISIS
WE JUST TALKED ABOUT RENTER'S-
WE WOULD VOTED TODAY ON THE
FLOOR ON ON ON RENTER'S
ASSISTANCE SO HE KEEPS COMING
UP- WE NEED MORE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PERIOD. THANK YOU KNOW
IT'S A GREAT QUESTION AND
BASICALLY WHAT I'VE TRIED TO DO
IS TO CREATE TO PASS ONE WITH A
GREATER INCENTIVE WHICHIS FOR
AFFORDABLE AND WORKFORCE HOUSING
AND AS THE L. A. TIMES IN AN
EDITORIAL NOTED I THINK ABOUT
THREE WEEKS AGO. CALIFORNIA
NEEDS HOUSING ACROSS THE
SPECTRUM WE NEED ALL TYPES OF
HOUSING BUT WE NEED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING MORE SO THAN THAT'S THE
MOST CRITICAL NEED- SO I TRIED
TO SORT OF CREATE AN INCENTIVE
WHERE THERE'S AN EASIER PATH
FORWARD. IF YOU'RE GONNA DO
AFFORDABLE AND WORKFORCE HOUSING
YOU GET OVER THE COUNTER
APPROVAL. IF YOU'RE GONNA DO
MARKET RATE HOUSING I STILL
WANTED TO CREATE A PROCESS BUT
WITHIN THAT PROCESS HAVE SOME
SAFEGUARDS FOR COMMUNITIES THAT
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO NEGATIVELY
IMPACT THE ARENA APPROACH SO. IF
YOU CAN SHOW THAT YOUR MARKET
RATE HOUSING PRODUCTION IS NOT
GOING TO IMPACT THAT CITY'S
ABILITY TO PROVIDE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND SOME OTHER LOCAL
HAVE A PASSED SO I'M TRYING TO
INCENTIVIZE ONE. BY MAKING THAT
PATH EASIER BUT NOT SHUT THE
DOOR ON THE OTHER COMPLETELY IF
YOU MEET THOSE CERTAIN
SAFEGUARDS AND SELF I'M TRYING
TO HIT THE SWEET SPOT BECAUSE AS
YOU KNOW WITH WITH PRIOR
LEGISLATION AND I KNOW- THE
CHAIR OF HOUSING- IS A IS A BIG.
PROPONENT OF THAT WITH PRIOR
LEGISLATION- IT WAS JUST TO DO
AWAY WITH PARKING MINIMUMS WITH
NO. CONDITIONS IN THERE ISN'T
THERE IS A BODY OF DATA TO SHOW
THAT THAT IS AN EFFECTIVE
STRATEGY THAT THERE'S BEEN SOME
SUCCESS BUT IN MY MIND MAKING
SURE THAT WE INCENTIVIZE THE
AFFORDABLE PIECE IS THE PROPER
TRADE OFF MAKING IT AN EASIER
PATH AND I GO BACK TO. SOMETHING
FROM MY LOCAL GOVERNMENT DAYS%
WHERE THEY SAID CREATE AN
INCENTIVE TO WHERE YOU WANT
PEOPLE TO GO WHETHER THAT'S
HAVING AN EASIER PATH FOR A
SINGLE STORY VERSUS A TWO STORY
AND THAT'S THAT WAS SORT OF THE
APPROACH SHOULDN'T AND LAST YEAR
WHEN I HELD. THE BILL FOLKS SAID
WELL PORTANTINO WHAT'S YOUR
ALTERNATIVE AND SO I TOOK THAT
CHALLENGE SERIOUSLY AND THIS IS
MY ATTEMPT TO TRY TO HIT THAT
SWEET SPOT AND BALANCE YOUR
CONCERNS ON THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PIECE IN THE WORK FORCE
HOUSING PEACE. WITH THE THOSE
FOLKS WHO THINK THE MARKET. WILL
WILL DELIVER THOSE THANKS I'M
TRYING TO HIT THAT SWEET SPOT.
AND FRANKLY I THINK BOTH SIDES
ARE LITTLE ONE EVEN. ARE UNEASY
WHICH MEANS I'M PROBABLY CLOSE
TO THAT TO THAT SWEET SPOT- ONE
OF MY CONCERNS WITH ANOTHER
ANOTHER VERSION OF THIS BILL AS
FAR AS PARKING REQUIREMENTS IS
THAT- THERE WOULD BE PARKING FOR
ELECTRIC VEHICLES I DON'T KNOW
WHERE IT YOUR BILL SOUNDS WITH
THAT BUT- HERE WE GO AGAIN WITH
EQUITY ISSUES RIGHT SO IF YOU
HAVE A NICE. TESLA RIGHT THEN
THERE WILL BE PARKING FOR YOU
THAT DOES TAKE UP THE SPACE FOR
AN ANOTHER UNIT OF HOUSING BUT
DON'T USE THE OTHER KIND OF
AUTOMOBILE WHICH IS WHAT MOST
LOW INCOME MODERATE INCOME
PEOPLE HAVE BECAUSE THAT'S ALL
THEY CAN AFFORD- SO IT TO ME
IT'S LIKE WAIT A MINUTE I
THOUGHT I THOUGHT WE WERE TRYING
TO GET TO MORE HOUSING BUT
YOU'RE MAKING THIS EXCEPTION SO
IS THAT A FOR YOU- AND I ALSO
AGREE WITH- CENTER HERTZBERG THE
LABOR ISSUES I HOPE. YOU WORK ON
THOSE AND ADDRESS THOSE CONCERNS
NOW I WILL TRY MY BEST AND I DO
WANT TO GIVE A SHOUT OUT TO THE
CHAIR AS WELL HE ORIGINALLY HI I
SAID AFFORDABLE WORK FORCE AND
THEN OBVIOUSLY THE CHAIR
MENTIONED STUDENTS AND THAT'S
THE SEGMENT OF OUR POPULATION
THAT YOU KNOW NEEDS MORE HOUSING
AS WELL AS WE'VE SEEN IN
BERKELEY AND SO THEY'RE ALSO
PART OF THAT 5% THE STUDENT
HOUSING SO- I'M TRYING TO TAKE
THE INPUT I'M TRYING TO BE AS
PRAGMATIC AND YOU KNOW SORT OF
REFEREE BETWEEN THE OPPOSING
VIEWS ON THIS AND- THIS IS MY
FIRST POLICY COMMITTEE IN THE
FIRST STABENOW'S. MICE FROM SAN
. MANSION WE'VE TAKEN SOME
AMENDMENTS UP TO THIS POINT AS
WELL SO. I'M LOOKING TAKES TO
GET THE INPUT AND CONTINUE BUT I
DO THINK. THERE'S A ROLE FOR US
TO PLAY. IN DEFINING WHAT WE
WANT OUT OF THIS PARKING
DISCUSSION AND I THINK AGAIN
GOING BACK WITH THE L. A. TIMES
SAID WE NEED HOUSING. BUT WE
NEED MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
THAN THAN OTHERS AND SO THAT'S
WHAT I'M REALLY TRYING TO MAKE
SURE WE GET IN ONE OF MY
CONCERNS ABOUT. IF YOU CREATE
SUCH A DESIRABLE. AREA YOU KNOW
WITHOUT. CONTROLS THOSE RIGHTS
EVEN IF THEY START. BEING A
LITTLE BIT MORE. LESS EXPENSIVE
THAN IF IT HAD PARKING OVER
TIME. THE DESIRABILITY WILL
DRIVE UP THOSE COSTS AND THEN
WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO. PRICE
OUT MIDDLE CLASS TEACHERS
FIREFIGHTERS WERE WORKING TO
PRICE THEM OUT AND SO I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE GET THAT
BALANCE SO THAT'S MY GOAL- AND
LIKE I SAID I'M GETTING HIT FROM
BOTH SIDES SO THAT MEANS I'M-
PROBABLY. DOING THE RIGHT THING.
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE IF THAT. TAKE OUT OF MY
CLOTHES MANAGER VERY GOOD EIGHT
I WILL AND I APPRECIATE THAT-
THERE IS A MOTION- THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMEND AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON HOUSING. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR CAMBIADO
I CABALLERO HI SENATOR NIELSEN
ALL RIGHT NIELSEN HI SENATOR
DORADO. DORADO HI SENATOR
HERTZBERG. SENATOR WIENER WIENER
HI. BORDER ZERO MOTION PASSES
FORTY ZERO THANK YOU SO MUCH
THEY WILL MOVE ON TO YOUR SECOND
BILL THAT TEARING COMMITTEE
WHICH IS SB. ELEVEN SEVENTY
SEVEN- YOU MAY PROCEED THANK YOU
A MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
BEFORE BEGAN I'D LIKE TO ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS OUTLINE
IN THE ANALYSIS- SO THANK YOU
AGAIN TO YOUR STAFF AND MY STAFF
FOR WORKING- IN CONCERT WITH
EACH OTHER. AS WE KNOW
CALIFORNIA IS IN THE MIDST OF A
HOUSING CRISIS WHICH WE'VE ALL
JUST TALKED ABOUT IT WILL
CONTINUE TO TALK ABOUT TO WE
pCALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED BY THE HIGH COST OF
HOUSING AND DEVASTATING EFFECT
IT'S HAD ON. IN PARTICULAR LOW
INCOME HOUSING RENTS AND HOME
PRICES HAVE OUTPACED WAGE GROWTH
FOR MOST OF- THE HOMES
THROUGHOUT THE REGION AND
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA LOWER
INCOME RESIDENTS OF PASADENA
GLENDALE AND BURBANK HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED PARTICULARLY HARD. AS
THE HIGH COST OF HOUSING FOR THE
REGION HAS OUTPACED THOSE IN
SURROUNDING LOS ANGELES AREAS-
AND SO THEY'VE COME TOGETHER TO
WANT TO ADDRESS IT AS THREE
CITIES- SO SB ELEVEN SEVENTY
SEVEN CREATES A REGIONAL HOUSING
TRUST. THAT WOULD BE
ADMINISTERED BY JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY- BETWEEN BURBANK
GLENDALE AND PASADENA THE JPA
WOULD BE ALLOWED TO REQUEST AND
RECEIVE PRIVATE AND STATE
FUNDING ALLOCATIONS AS WELL AS
AUTHORIZED ISSUE OF BONDS. TO
HELP FINANCE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECTS FOR PERSONS AND
FAMILIES OF EXTREMELY LOW VERY
LOW AND MODERATE INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS HELP ADDRESS THIS
LOCAL AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS
BETWEEN THE THREE CITIES. LET ME
SET BETWEEN THE THREE CITIES WE
HAVE MORE THAN THREE THOUSAND
NEW AFFORDABLE UNITS IN
DEVELOPMENT THAT'S GREAT FOR
THESE THREE CITIES- AND I
APPLAUD THEM AND THEY HAVE BEEN
WORKING DILIGENTLY OVER THE PAST
DECADE. TO MEET THE DEMANDS AND
TO MEET THE RENO NUMBERS
CREATING THEIR OWN GPS JPA WILL
ALLOW THE CITIES TO WORK ON
FUNDING FOR THE FOUNDER PORTABLE
HOUSING UNITS LOCALLY WITHIN THE
REGION THROUGH THE HOUSING TRUST
FUND INSTEAD OF HAVING TO GO. TO
MULTIPLE OTHER JP ACE OR TO THE
STATE OF THE CITIES WANT TO
BRING NEW AFFORDABLE
DEVELOPMENTS TO THE REGION AND
TACKLING THIS CRISIS IS
SOMETHING WE SHOULD ALL GET
BEHIND WITH ME TODAY ON THE
PHONE TO TESTIFY I HAVE. MAYOR
TELE MONTEZ FROM BURBANK AND
MAYOR GORDO FROM. PASADENA AND
ALSO BILL LONG THE DIRECTOR OF
HOUSE FOR THE C. OF PASSAGE IS
ON THE- FOR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
SO. THE TWO MAYORS ARE HERE
SPEAKER ON THE PHONE TO SPEAK.
VERY GOOD IF WE COULD START WITH
GESTEL AMOUNT IS THE MAYOR FROM
THE CITY OF BURBANK FIRST PLEASE. YES GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE-
THANK YOU CARE COVER YOUR-
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. THE
SPECIAL THANK YOU TO SIR
PORTANTINO. FOR SPONSORING
SENATE BILL ELEVEN SEVENTY
SEVEN. YES HELLO ABOUT HIS WELL
AS FOR ASSEMBLY FOR YOU TODAY
DENNIS FOR YOUR OF S. B. HELLO
SEVENTY SO. TO CREATE THE
BURBANK GLENDALE. REACHING
HOUSING TRUST IF THE TRUST BE A
CRITICAL TOOL FOR TRI CITY AREA
TO RECEIVE FUNDING FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THE REGION
. OUR REGION WITH MAJOR MAJOR
EMPLOYERS EXCELLENT
TRANSPORTATION UP TO THE LONG
HISTORY OF WORKING TOGETHER.
WHAT THREE CITIES HAVE A HISTORY
OF THE BASEMENT TO IMPROVE THE
QUALITY OF LIFE FOR RESIDENTS IN
REGION THROUGH PARTNERSHIPS SUCH
AS A PRETTY GOOD JOB CENTER. A
ROLL YOU OVER TO A COMMUNITIES
JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY. AND OF
COURSE THE BURKE THE HOLLYWOOD
BURBANK AIRPORT. THIS PROPOSAL
WILL HAVE INTERESTS IS ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY TO COOPERATE. ON THE
CREATION OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
THE HOUSING CRISIS CANNOT BE
SOLVED INDEPENDENTLY. AND WE ARE
COMMITTED TO WORKING TOGETHER TO
ADD TO THE THOUSANDS OF UNITS
ALREADY DEVELOPED IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND IN OUR
RESPECTIVE DEVELOPMENT BY
PLANES. IN BURBANK THERE ARE
CURRENTLY FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE UNITS IN THE PIPELINE TO
REMAIN AFFORDABLE TO LOWER
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS. YET THERE
STILL ISN'T ENOUGH BURBANK'S
REGIONAL HOUSING NEEDS
ASSESSMENT ARENA NUMBERS IS.
EIGHT THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED
SEVENTY TWO UNITS AND BURBANK
DIFFICULT TO BUILD TWELVE
THOUSAND UNITS BY TWENTY THIRTY
FIVE. THE FUNDS RECEIVED THROUGH
THE PROPOSED REGIONAL TRUST
COULD BRING. TO WORK TOWARD THAT
. WE REALIZE PROPOSED REVEAL
HOUSING TRUST IS NOT GOING TO
SOLVE THE HOUSING CRISIS IN THE
CRAZY REGION. HOWEVER WILL BE
CRITICAL FINANCING TOOL FOR
PROJECTS THAT ARE SMALL FOR LACK
OF FUNDING IN OUR PARTNER CITIES
OF GLENDALE. AND PASADENA. IF
YOU HEALTH BUNDLES. SITES TO
BURBANK IT USUALLY O TRANSFER-
IMPORTANCE. AND WOULDN'T TO GO
BURKE. THANK FOR YOUR TIME IN
THIS FOR YOURSELF OF SENATE BILL
IT SEVENTY SEVEN HAVE A GOOD DAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTING. NOW WILL MOVE TO VICTOR
GORDO CITY OF PASADENA. THANK
YOU. VETERANS I THINK HI I'M YOU
CAN BE UP DEFINITE SUPPORTER SB. ONE THOUSAND. THANK YOU SIR
PORTANTINO PREVIOUS LETTER FOR
WORK- YOU ALL HOUSE IS CREATE A
ONCE THE BEST ADDRESS WILL WORK
. S. ONE SEVEN ALLOW CLINTON
BILL FOR WE CAN THE CHORE
EFFORTS REDUCE AND REYES. WITH
CRAFT HOW CRISES. R. THREE
CITIES YOU KNOW HAVE AT BEING AN
ARCTIC TO CONTINUE TO ALL THAT
WE CAN TO COULD AND RETAIN
BEFORE HEALTH. PASSED YOU KNOW A
LOT FOR STRUCK. OVER THREE YOU
THE LAST FOUR YEARS AND WE GOT
HAVE ONE THOUSAND MORE THE PIPE
AS WE SPEAK THERE ARE HUNDRED
FOR HOUSING COULD PASS INCLUDE.
PERMANENCE OF HAVE AND- FOR OUR
BETTER- M. BILLS WORK WHO ALMOST
THESE PROJECTS ARE FUNDED OKAY
ONE SO WILL ALLOW WAS CONSTRUCT
HUNDREDS MORE MAKES ON THIS BILL
WILL ALL SUBMIT HAS. FOR
GLENDALE ON ONCE JOIN OTHER JOBS
MORE HOUSING ABOUT PROVIDING TO
EASY VEHICLE TO RACE AND FINISH
PROJECTS IN THE PIPELINE AND
CONTINUE TO PLAN FOR HUNDREDS
MORE UNITS HIGHER TO. OF IN- IN
THE AFFIRMATIVE AND- YES
UNDERSTOOD PORTENT LEGISLATION
TO OUR REGION. THANK YOU ALL
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
YOUR TEST AND THANK YOU- MISTER
BILL ONE FOR- BEING ON THE LINE
IN- FOR- QUESTIONS THE EVENT
HAVE ANY WE'RE MOVE ON TO SO. IN
I WANT TO SEE IF ANY IN RE. TWO
TWENTY TWO TWO ZEROS IS IN THERE
IS. C. GOOD MORNING THERE ARE
ALSO BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
GLENDALE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU. VERY GOOD IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE IN IN THIS
ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
. SINGMAN WE'LL MOVE ON TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE MADAM
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD CHECK.
THANK YOU. IF YOU WERE IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. ONE ONE SEVEN
SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS. ONE NINE
ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS ONE AND THEN
ZERO YOUR IN SUPPORT. BUT THE.
ELEVEN SEVENTY SEVEN. AND
MEDICARE WITH NO SUPPORT QUEUE
AT THIS TIME VERY GOOD WILL MOVE
ON TO OPPOSITION IS THERE
ANYBODY IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED THAT THAT WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. THING THEN
WE'LL MOVE ON TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LANE MADAME
MODERATOR COULD YOU CHECK IF
THERE'S ANYBODY THAT WANTS TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF. ELEVEN
SEVENTY SEVEN. THANK YOU CAN
OPPOSITION OF AT ELEVEN SEVENTY
SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AGAIN THAT'S ONE AND THEN
ZERO IN OPPOSITION OF ES B.
ELEVEN SEVENTY SEVEN. MADAM
CHAIR WE HAVE NOT VISION A QUEUE
AT THIS TIME VERY GOOD A BRING
THE MATTER BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
SENATOR HERTZBERG. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MA'AM SURE LOOK IS A
GREAT IDEA I THINK WE DID THIS
COUPLE YEARS LARGE CARRIED ME. I
THINK SO- BUT IT'S AN EXCELLENT
EXCELLENT IDEA AND I WANT TO
MOVE THE BILL AND TO COMMEND THE
AUTHOR AND TO. SEE A LOT OF MY
FRIEND JESSE TELLEMENT THIS IN
BURBANK. WE SHARE THE SAME
COMMUNITIES SENATOR PORTANTINO
NINE HE DOES A GREAT JOB SO WITH
THAT. BEGIN I'M OF THE BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THANKS
FOR- INTRODUCING THIS MEASURE.
REGGAE ANY OTHER COMMENTS. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
ABOUT THE CENTER PARTY WOULD YOU
LIKE TO COOK CONCLUDE I THANK
THE MAYORS FOR BEING HERE AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THAT
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT
FIRST AMEND AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON HOUSING THE ROLE
PLEASE SENATOR CAMBIADO HI
CABALLERO HI SENATOR NIELSEN. I
NIELSEN I ASSUME DOLE. DORADO
HIS SENATOR. HERTZBERG FIVE
SENATOR WIENER. THE VOTE IS FOR
EYES NOSE ZERO ABOUT WILL HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN FOR SENATOR WIENER
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
PORTANTINO WE'RE GONNA MOVE BACK
TO SENATOR NEWMAN. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE SENATOR NEWMAN. WE
WILL BE TAKING UP ITEM NUMBER
FIVE ON THE AGENDA SB NINE
NINETY ONE. FLOOR'S YOURS. THANK
YOU MORE GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- I AM HERE
TODAY TO PRESENT SB NINE NINETY
ONE SB NINE ANYONE WILL ALLOW%
LOCAL WATER AGENCIES TO CONTRACT
WITH ENTITIES THAT THEY USE THE
PROGRESSIVE DESIGN BUILD
CONTRACTING MODEL IN THE
EXECUTION CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
WORKS PROJECTS THE MORE
TRADITIONAL COMMONLY DEPLOYED
DESIGN BUILD CONTRACTING MODEL
DEVELOPS DESIGN PACKAGES BASED
ON PARAMETERS FROM THE AGENCY
TYPICALLY WITHOUT WITHOUT THE
AGENCIES DIRECT INPUT DURING THE
DESIGN PROCESS. THE DESIGN BUILD
METHOD IS USEFUL FOR PROJECTS
THAT ARE NOT EXPECTED TO CHANGE
BUT CAN BE LESS EFFICIENT AND
MORE COSTLY IF THERE ARE
MATERIAL CHANGES MADE TO A
PROJECT SCOPE THE PROGRESSIVE
DESIGN BUILD CONTRACTING MODEL
IS A MODEL IN WHICH A SINGLE
ENTITY IS HIRED AS EARLY AS
POSSIBLE IN THE PROJECT TO DO
BOTH THE DESIGN AND CONSTRUCTION
WORK FOR THE PROJECT IN RECENT
YEARS THE PROGRESSIVE DESIGN
BUILD MODEL HAS INCREASED IN
POPULARITY BECAUSE IT REPRESENTS
A VERY COST EFFECTIVE FORM OF
COLLABORATIVE PROJECT
DEVELOPMENT. PROGRESS TO DESIGN
BUILD OFFERS AN AGENCY
OPPORTUNITY TO BRING A DESIGN
BUILDER OF THE PROJECT TEAM AND
EARLY POINT THE DESIGN PHASES
COLLABORATION CAN REDUCE OVERALL
PROJECT RISKS COSTS AND EXPEDITE
SCHEDULES UNDER CURRENT STATUTE
HOWEVER THERE ARE EXPLICIT
SPECIFICATIONS AND LIMITS ON THE
TYPES OF CONTRACTING MODELS THAT
LOCAL AGENCIES ARE PERMITTED TO
UTILIZED IN THE CONSTRUCTION OF
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS IN
CALIFORNIA IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THE LEGISLATIVE GRANT THE
LEGISLATURE GRANTED THE DIRECTOR
GENERAL SERVICES. THE AUTHORITY
TO USE THE PDB METHOD FOR UP TO
THREE PUBLIC WORKS PROJECTS THAT
WOULD BENEFIT FROM THIS
CONTRACTING METHOD ABOVE THAT
NUMBER HOWEVER LOCAL AGENCIES
ARE REQUIRED TO SEE CAN RECEIVE
LEGISLATIVE APPROVAL IN ORDER TO
BE PERMITTED TO CONTRACT WITH AN
ENTITY THAT UTILIZES THE
PROGRESSIVE DESIGN BUILD METHOD
FOR DEVELOPING PUBLIC WORKS
PROJECTS RECENT DATA AND
FORECASTS HAVE SHOWN THE
CALIFORNIA WILL NEED TO DEVELOP
SUBSTANTIAL ADDITIONAL CAPACITY
TO TREAT WATER FORTUNATELY
TECHNOLOGICAL ADVANCEMENTS THAT
ARE HAVE OPENED THE DOOR TO NEW
OPPORTUNITIES TO CONVERT WASTE
WATER INTO DRINKING WATER IN
ORDER TO DO SO AT SCALE THOUGH.
CALIFORNIA SURPRISINGLY SIX
HUNDRED LOCAL WATER AGENCIES
WILL NEED TO INVEST IN NEW
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT INCORPORATES
INNOVATIVE TREE EVEN METHODS BY
ALL. THE X. UNIVERSE. OF
PROGRESSIVE DESIGN BUILD AS A
CONTRACTING MODEL SB NINETY A
NEW ONE WILL ALLOW LOCAL WATER
AGENCIES TO MAKE NECESSARY COST
EFFECTIVE INVESTMENTS IN NEW
PUBLIC WORKS PROJECTS TO MEET
THE STATE'S GROWING. WATER
TREATMENT NEEDS HERE WITH ME TO
TESTIFY IN PERSON THIS AFTERNOON
ARE MATT SCOTT SENIOR VICE
PRESIDENT RIGHT IN DISTRICT
MANAGER OF THE CUBIC
CORPORATION. ONE OF NORTH
AMERICA'S LARGEST AND MOST
EXPERIENCED ENGINEERING AND
CONSTRUCTION FIRMS. AS WELL AS
KEY DONE ON BEHALF OF THE WATER
COLLABORATIVELY RESEARCH ISSUE
CALIFORNIA. I RESPECTFULLY
ASKING FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THIS
AFTERNOON. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER SCOTT A GOOD AFTERNOON-
THIS QUEUE IT IS WITH THEM AND
ONE OF NORTH AMERICA'S LARGEST
AND MOST RESPECTED ENGINEERING
CONSTRUCTION COMPANIES- AND KEEP
ITS COMMITMENT TOWARD CRAFT
EMPLOYEES THEIR SAFETY PROJECT
QUALITY ENVIRONMENTAL
STEWARDSHIP BURKE INGRAINED IN
EVERYTHING WE DO HE WAS A MEMBER
OF THE WATER COLLABORATIVE
DELIVERY ASSOCIATION THE SPONSOR
OF SB NINE NINETY ONE. SB NINE
NINETY ONE WILL GIVE CITIES
COUNTIES AND LOCAL AGENCIES A
POWERFUL TOOL TO DELIVER
PROJECTS USING THE PROGRESSIVE
DESIGN BUILD METHOD. D. B. AS A
VALUABLE FORM OF COLLABORATIVE
PROJECT DELIVERY AND DELIVERY
AND CAN PROVIDE MULTIPLE
BENEFITS WHEN USED TO EXECUTE
COMPLEX PUBLIC WORKS PROJECT.
PTV IS A PROJECT DELIVERY METHOD
THAT ALLOWS THE PROJECT TEAM TO
COLLABORATIVELY PERFORM DESIGN
CONSTRUCTION ENGINEERING PROJECT
MANAGEMENT AND CONSTRUCTION
ACCORDING TO DESIGN PARAMETERS
PERFORMANCE CRITERIA AND OTHER
REQUIREMENTS ESTABLISHED. BY THE
PUBLIC AGENCY OWNERS PTV
DELIVERY BENEFITS THE PUBLIC
AGENCY OWNER BY PROVIDING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADD THE DESIGN
BUILD TEAM TO THE OVERALL
PROJECT TEAM EARLY IN THE DESIGN
PHASE. ACCORDING TO PUBLIC
AGENCY OWNER AND DESIGN BUILD
TEAM ENABLING THE PUBLIC AGENCY
OWNER AND DESIGN BUILD TEAM MORE
OPPORTUNITIES TO COLLABORATE
DURING THE PROJECT DESIGN
PHASES. EARLY COLLABORATION IS
KEY TO REDUCING PROJECT RISK
COST AND SCHEDULE. OUR ECONOMY
AND CITIZENS DEPEND ON A
RELIABLE SUPPLY WATER TO REMAIN
GLOBALLY COMPETITIVE SB NINE
NINETY ONE WILL ALLOW THE
DELIVERY OF PROJECTS TO TREAT
WATER RECYCLE WATER OR PRODUCE
ADVANCED TREATED WATER TO
EFFICIENTLY AND EFFECTIVELY TO
BE A FIFTH EFFICIENTLY AND
EFFECTIVELY STREAMLINED. S. B.
NINE NINETY ONE IS JUST ANOTHER
TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX A PUBLIC
AGENCY OWNERS CAN USE TO DELIVER
PROJECTS EFFECTIVELY FOR THAT
REASON I ASK YOUR VOTE IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE NINETY ONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY. THREE
DONE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS KEITH ON BEHALF OF THE
WATER CLAMOR OF DELIVERY
SENSATIONAL THE REAL QUICK IF
WE'RE IN A DROUGHT WE NEED TO
EMPOWER AGENCIES TO DELIVER
WATER WE ALL NEED IT ECONOMY
NEEDS IT I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU. VERY GOOD IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED.
VENTURE MEMBERS MIKE MADIGAN ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OR
ANYONE ELSE. THING THEN MADAM
MODERATOR ARE GOING TO GO TO THE
TELE TELECONFERENCE LINE AND ASK
IF THERE'S ANYBODY THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
NINE NINETY ONE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT ABOUT EIGHTY NINE
NINETY ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ENVIRO. AGAIN THAT'S ONE AND
THEN IN SUPPORT OF AB T. NINE
ONE. IT WILL CUT THE LINE FORTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WHEN I
WOULD HAVE PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON THE
HOSPITALITY WATER SPORT YOU
CAN'T. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
PLACE. IN THANK YOU NEXT LINE
THE SIXTY TWO YEAR LINE AT THE
END. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS A LOT
THOUGH ON BEHALF OF INLAND
EMPIRE UTILITIES AGENCY AND
WATER RE USE CALIFORNIA BOTH IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT PLEASE. IF YOU
WERE A BOTTOM LINE IS SIXTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THE GIFT ON THE
HALF OF THE AMERICAN
SUBCONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA AND ITS HUNDREDS OF
SUBCONTRACTING COMPANIES WE
SUPPORT THE SENSIBLE MEASURE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR WE HAVEN'T WE DO HAVE ONE
QUEUING UP. ONE MOMENT WELL
GIVEN THEIR LINE NUMBER. AGAIN
WE ARE ON- SUPPORT OF S. B. NINE
NINE ONE.
THANK YOU AND WE WILL GO TO LINE
. MY NUMBER SIXTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
WHAT CALIFORNIA UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION AND FOR. VERY GOOD
THANK YOU SO MUCH. IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE IN MEMORY HAVE NO
FURTHER SUPPORTED. VERY GOOD
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NOW TO
OPPOSITION IS OR ANYBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED IN OPPOSITION
TO SB NINE NINE ONE. THING NO
MOVEMENT MADAM MODERATOR WE'RE
GONNA MOVE TO TELECONFERENCE
LINE IS THERE ANYBODY ON THE
LINE IN OPPOSITION TO SB NINE
NINE ONE. THEY GIVE YOU AN
UPDATE OF SB NINE NINE ONE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AGAIN THAT THE AND THEN. FOR
OPPOSITION OF SB. NINE NINE ONE.
FOR MM WE HAVE NO OPPOSITION IN
Q. VERY GOOD WILL BRING THE
MATTER BACK TO CAMP- THE
COMMITTEE- ARE THERE ANY
COMMENTS- THE BILL. THERE MOTION
HAS BEEN MADE- SENATOR NEWMAN I
WANNA THANK YOU FOR- AUTHORING
THIS BILL I THINK- DEPICTION PD
B. IS A GOOD WAY TO BRING IN
PROJECTS- MUCH USUALLY AHEAD OF
SCHEDULE- WITHOUT THE CHANGE
ORDERS- ON THE COSTLY CHANGE
ORDERS AND- AND CONFLICTS THAT
CAN OCCUR WHEN YOU HAVE ONE
PERSON DESIGNING THE PROJECT IN
ANOTHER CONSTRUCTING AND MISSED
ANY MISUNDERSTANDS IT THAT THAT
OCCURRED BECAUSE OF THAT SO IT
IS COST EFFECTIVE IN IT IT
REDUCES RISKS AND FOR THAT
MATTER A MINUTE. AT REASON I'M
GONNA BE SUPPORTING IT TODAY
THERE'S A MOTION IT IS DUE
PASSED BUT FIRST TO BE RE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SEVEN KIRBY AUTO HI
CABALLERO HI SIR NEAL. HI
NIELSEN HI SOME DURO. DORADO BY
SEN BIRDS. HERTZBERG BY SENATOR
WIENER. FOUR ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES FOR TWO ZERO WITH ABOUT
WE WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR
SENATOR WIENER THANK YOU MEASURE
THANK YOU MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- SENATOR HERTZBERG SERVICES
OKAY JUST WANT TO CHECK YES.
MORE HEARING. HAPPILY IN OTHER
SO WE DO HAVE THAT AS HEARD ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT WE'RE GOING TO GO
OUT OF- THERE IS A- APPOINTMENT
TO BE MADE SO WILL TAKE UP ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN WHICH IS SB EIGHT
NINETY ONE BY SENATOR HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. MADAM CHAIR.
YOU KNOW THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
HAS THE FEDERAL CLEAN WATER ACT
THAT REQUIRES ANY DISCHARGE TO
RECORD NPDES PERMIT IN THE
INDUSTRIAL SECTOR THAT PERMITS
CALLED THE- INDUSTRIAL GENERAL
PERMIT I DID A BILL A FEW YEARS
AGO THEY BASICALLY TRIED TO
REQUIRES CITIES TO GET THAT
DATA. BUT BILL NUMBER WAS I
CAN'T REMEMBER AS TO A FIVE OR
SOMETHING I DID A BILL THE
NUMBER OF YEARS AGO AND I
BASICALLY SAID IF THERE'S A
BUSINESS LICENSE WILL APPARENTLY
SOME CITIES HAVE WHAT'S CALLED A
BUSINESS CERTIFICATE SO WE NOW
HAVE TO CLARIFY THE LAW TO MAKE
SURE THAT FOLKS THAT ARE JUST
CHARGING A INTO THESE A WATER
WAYS- ARE INCLUDED- 95% OF ALL
CALIFORNIA WATERWAYS ARE
CONSIDERED IMPAIRED OR HIGHLY
POLLUTED. THAT FRAMEWORK WE
REGISTER TWO THOUSAND NEW AYE
KYI AYE G. P. ENROLLEES AND SO
WE'RE JUST TRYING TO FILL THE
FIX THE WHOLE THERE AND WITH
THAT WE HAVE A WITNESS I BELIEVE
WHO'S GOING TO TESTIFY JOHN
BOTHWELL THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF CALIFORNIA BECAUSE KEEPERS
ALLIANCE THANK YOU MAY BE
SEATED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CA.GOV FIFTEEN IN CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- SEAN BOSWELL
IN THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE KEEP RELIANCE
BE REPRESENTED BY TEN WATER
KEEPERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
WORKING MOSTLY ON WATER QUALITY
ISSUES- AS CENTER HERTZBERG
MENTIONED SB TWO OH FIVE WE WAS
PASSED IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN-
AND WE REALLY TRY TO PUT AN
ELEGANT SOLUTION INTO THAT BILL
AND THE WAY WE DID IT WAS VERY
STREAMLINED. OR ESSENTIALLY THE
BUSINESS APPLICANT COMES TO THE
MUNICIPALITY HAS A FOUR DIGIT S.
I. C. CODE THAT THEY PUT IN
THEIR APPLICATION AND IF THAT
CODE MATCHES UP WITH WHAT'S ON
THE WEBSITE STATE WATER BOARD
THEN THEY NEED TO PROVIDE ONE
MORE IDENTIFICATION NUMBER THAT
THEY DID PROPERLY IN ROLE IS
VERY ELEGANT SOLUTION- AND BUT
IT WAS REALLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE
IT LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD
BETWEEN ALL INDUSTRIES. I THEN
HAD TO UNROLL IT ON THIS PERMIT
BEFORE TWO OH FIVE WE ESTIMATE
THERE WAS OVER TWENTY THOUSAND
NON FILERS WHICH WERE CALLING
PEOPLE THAT DIDN'T STOP AND ROLL
INTO THE UNDER THE PERMIT- WE
ARE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT- AND IT'S
BEEN LARGELY VERY SUCCESSFUL-
THROUGH THE TWO YEARS OF
IMPLEMENTATION- CENTER HERTZBERG
MENTIONED THE TWO THOUSAND-
INDUSTRIAL PROPERTIES BUT OVER
SEVEN THOUSAND FOLKS THAT WERE
NON FILED BEFORE. HAVE NOW
EITHER ENROLLED EITHER GOT AN
EXEMPTION OR ARE UNDER THE
PERMIT SO THE BILL IN THE
PROGRAM IS WORKING THERE WERE
SOME PROBLEMS DURING
IMPLEMENTATION AS CENTER EXPERT
MENTIONED SOME OF THE CITIES
CALL IT BY A DIFFERENT NAME IT'S
NOT A LICENSES THE CERTIFICATE-
AND THEN ALSO SOME INFORMATION
WASN'T NECESSARILY PROVIDED-
WHEN PUBLIC WOULD REQUESTED AND
SO THAT ALL THERE IS A LARGE
AMOUNT OF EXEMPTIONS THAT THESE
INDUSTRIES SELF PROCLAIMED THAT
THEY HAD AND SO WE JUST WANT TO
VERIFY. THAT THOSE EXEMPTIONS
ARE PROPER AND THAT'S ALL A LOT
WITH BILL DOES AS WELL. I'M
SOMEONE TOUCH ON THREE QUICK IS
THAT WAS IN THE AND NOW. OF THE
BETWEEN LICENSE SINCE. AGAIN
WHEN YOU'RE DOING SB TWO OH FIVE
THAT WAS LARGELY THE CONCERN WE
GOT WAS THAT A BUSINESS LICENSE
IS REALLY JUST AN OPPORTUNITY TO
TAKE SOME FUNDING- THERE'S NOT
REALLY REGULATORY PROCESS TO
BACK AND WE WANT TO STICK WITH
THAT WE DON'T WANT TO ADD ANY
TYPE OF REGULATORY PROCESS AND
WE GET TO THAT IN A SECOND. BUT
THE IDEA IS SIMPLY TO LOOK IT UP
S. I. C. CODE NUMBER AND MATCH
IT UP NOT TO MAKE ANY REGULATORY
DECISIONS AND WE SPUR STICKING
WITH THAT HERE IN SB EIGHT.
EIGHT NINE ONE- AND THEN THE
SECOND ISSUE I WE'VE BEEN
DIGGING INTO. THE CITIES THAT DO
HAVE BUSINESS CERTIFICATES. AND
THEY SEEM TO BE NO DIFFERENT IN
PRACTICE THAN A BUSINESS LICENSE
OTHER THAN THE NAME. MANY
CERTIFICATES ASK FOR CERTAIN
THINGS LIKE. SB TWO FIVE DID
FORCIBLY G. ME DIFFERENT
ORDINANCES. AND YOU CHECK THE
BOX YES I'VE- APPLIED AND YOU
KNOW PASS THIS ORDINANCE NOT
THAT. TO THE IT'S ESSENTIALLY
THE SAME AS A LICENSE OTHER THAN
THE NAME. OF THE SECOND ISSUE
THERE WAS AN ISSUE ABOUT THE
PUBLIC RECORDS ACT REQUEST THAT
WAS IDENTIFIED THE ANALYSIS AND
I WOULD AGREE- WE'RE WE'RE
ACTUALLY WORKING ON SOME
POTENTIAL AMENDMENTS NOW. TO
MAKE IT A LOT MORE CLEAR OF
EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO GET
NOT A FULL PUBLIC RECORDS ACT
REQUEST. CITIES AND COUNTIES
ALREADY. NEED TO DISCLOSE DATE
NAME AND ADDRESS OF THE
APPLICANT- THAT APPLIED FOR THE
LICENSE. ALL WE'RE ASKING TO ADD
TO THAT IS THE IDENTIFICATION
NUMBER THAT THEY PROVIDED SAYING
THAT THEY'RE- COVERED UNDER THE
INDUSTRIAL STORMWATER PERMIT. SO
NOT TRYING TO OPEN IT UP FOR ANY
TYPE OF TAX OR FINANCIAL
INFORMATION. SO WE'RE GONNA.
TAKE AMENDMENTS TO NARROW THAT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT CONCERN
IS ALLEVIATED. AND THE LAST ONE
AND IT'S IN SUBSECTION I'D BUT-
ON IT WAS REFERENCING THE
ANALYSIS AND I DON'T NECESSARILY
AGREE WITH- THE WAY. SOME FOLKS
ARE READING IT BUT- THAT
PROVISION- IS BEING READ TO SAY
THAT IF YOU DON'T HAVE A
BUSINESS LICENSE OR CERTIFICATE
OR ANY TYPE OF THAT TYPE OF
PROGRAM. YOU ESSENTIALLY MIGHT
NEED TO CREATE ONE HUNDRED EIGHT
NINETY ONE. IT'S THE COMPLETE
OPPOSITE ACTUALLY WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO WE'RE TRYING TO
CLARIFY. THAT THE CITY OR THE
COUNTY HAS NO. REGULATORY
DECISION THAT THEY HAVE TO MAKE
ON WHETHER THEY HAVE TO COMPLY
WITH THE PERMANENT NOT. THAT'S A
REALLY BIG ISSUE WITH SOME OF
THE- LEAST CITIES AND THE
COUNTIES BACK INTO A FIVE. WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE HONOR THAT
COMMITMENT. THATWE'RE NOT
REQUIRING ANY TYPE OF NEW
REGULATORY DECISION MAKING
PROCESS. SO I'M COMMITTED- I
KNOW WE CAN WORK ON THE LANGUAGE
TO MAKE THAT CLEAR BECAUSE I
THINK WE'RE ON THE SAME PAGE
WITH SOME OF THE LOCL GUYS
THAT. HAVE THOSE CONCERNS. OR
WOULD YOU KNOW IF WE HAVE TO
WILL JUST REMOVE IT BECAUSE WE
REALLY WERE PUTTING IT IN THERE.
AS A SAFEGUARD FOR THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS NOT TRYING TO. PUT
ANY NEW ONEROUS ON. THEM SO THAT
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AND
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY HERE TODAY. THERE
ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF. S. EIGHT
NINETY ONE. YOUR IN ROOM. TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED. SAYING NO ONE MOVE
WILL GO TO THE TELECONFERENCE
LINE MADAM MODERATOR IF YOU
COULD AT QUERY WHETHER THERE'S
ANYBODY WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF THIS BILL
. THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF
AB DE. EIGHT NINETY ONE OF EIGHT
NINETY ONE THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
. THE WORST PART OF AT THE EIGHT
NINETY ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AND WE HAVE ONE
QUEUING UP ONE MOMENT WHAT WE
GIVE THEM MY NUMBER. AND AS A
REMINDER REAR IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. EIGHT NINETY ONE.
WE'LL GO TO LINE TWENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
KIRTI PHILLIPS I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE TENT CALIFORNIA
WATER KEEPERS PLANNING
CONSERVATION THE END THE CODES
ON BUYING THE RIGHT FOUNDATION
IN SUPPORT OF IT A NINETY ONE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. OR ANYONE
ELSE. THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO THE
NUMBER THEIR SUPPORT AND QUEUE
AT THIS TIME IT OBJECT. VERY
GOOD WILL MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION
IS OR ANYBODY THAT WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO- SB EIGHT
NINETY ONE IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED. SEEING NO MOVEMENT WILL
MOVE TO THE TELECONFERENCE LINE
. IS THERE ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. TO EIGHT
NINETY ONE. THANK YOU IN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. EIGHT NINETY
ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. AGAIN THAT ONE AND THEN
ZERO IN OPPOSITION. AND WE HAVE
NO OPPOSITION IN CUBA BY
MEDICARE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WILL BRING THE BILL BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE IS THERE ANYONE WHO
HAS ANY QUESTIONS I SEE NONE
SENATOR HERTZBERG YOU MAY
CONCLUDE. SESTRA ABLE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY. EMOTION WE DO NEED A
MOTION. DETAILS DETAILS THE
MOTION HAS BEEN MADE BY SENATOR
NELSON THANK YOU BOTH TO THE
CENTER NAY NIELSEN SENATOR
DORADO- THE AND THE MOTION NOW
THAT WE HAVE A MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST TO BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY. THE REAL PLACE SENATOR
CAMBIADO HI CABALLERO HI SENATOR
NIELSEN. NIELSEN AYE SENATOR
ALSO YOUR BROWSER HI SENATOR
HERTZBERG HI HERTZBERG AYE
SENATOR WIENER. ZERO EMOTION
PASSES FORTY ZERO AND WE WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR SENATOR
WE- WILL MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
ITEM WHICH IS AGAIN SENATOR
HERTZBERG'S SB NINE THIRTY EIGHT
THE FLOOR IS YOURS SIR. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR THIS BILL
RELATES TO THE KNOX CREEK THIRTY
EXCUSE ME CORTESE KNOCKS
HERTZBERG ACT THAT WE PASSED IN
TWO THOUSAND- YOU NINETIES REAL
BRIEFLY BECAUSE OUR MAKE THIS
BRIEF YOU MADAM CHAIR. YOU KNOW
GOVERNOR WILSON AND GIVE US
GOVERNOR BROWN THE FIRST
GOVERNOR ABOUT PAT BROWN THAT'S
THE FIRST FOR SECOND GOVERNOR
BROWNBACK BROWN DEALT WITH IS
THE IS CALIFORNIA IS GOING IT
JUST LEAPS AND BOUNDS DEALING
WITH THESE ISSUES OF. THESE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS AND SPECIAL
DISTRICTS AND CITIES AND
COUNTIES IN SPHERES OF INFLUENCE
IN CAME UP INITIALLY THAT IT WAS
JACK KNOX AND THEN TOM CORTESE
YOUR COLLEAGUE'S FATHER. AND
THEN ME AFTERWARDS AND PUT THE
SERIES OF LAWS TOGETHER THAT
REALLY DEAL WITH THE
ARCHITECTURE OF THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS AND IN TWO
THOUSAND AFTER FOUR YEARS OF
WORK IN TWO MILLION DOLLARS OF
INDEPENDENT WORK WITH OUTSIDE
GROUPS WE CAME UP WITH WITH- THE
BILL CORTESE KNOCKS HERTZBERG.
SINCE THEN THIS COMMITTEE I WAS
CALLED BECAUSE I CHAIRED THIS
COMMITTEE SOME YEARS AGO.
COMMITTEE OF EXCEPTIONS BECAUSE
EVERY TIME THERE'S ANOTHER
JURISDICTION THERE'S NOT BUT
LOCAL FIGHT OR WHATEVER THEY
KEEP MAKING CHANGES IN THIS. IS
WHAT WE HAVE BEFORE US IS A BILL
THAT IS THE RESULT OF A NUMBER
OF YEARS OF WITH THE SPECIAL
DISTRICTS AND OTHERS GOT
TOGETHER TRYING TO DEAL WITH
SOME OF THE CHALLENGES. RELATING
TO SPECIAL DISTRICTS- THE-
LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION DID A
REPORT WHICH THEN- ARTICULATED
SOME OF THOSE WEAKNESSES. AND
THEN IT AS A RESULT OF THE GROUP
SPECIAL DISTRICTS AND OTHERS
WILL IT WILL HAVE CAL ASCO COME
AND TALK PAN MILLER'S GONNA COME
AND TALK IN. MARKETS THAT
LETTERS THAT DID WONDERS SUN. NO
OKAY I'M CONFIRM THAT. EVEN IF
WORK SO MUCH WE WAS THE CHAIR.
HE WAS THE CHIEF STAFF PERSON
HERE. MANY IN TWENTY FIVE YEARS
AGO WHEN HE WAS A REAL PRINCIPLE
PART OF ALL THIS. AND SO. WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO AND WILL DO
EXPLAIN TO YOU WHAT THE ISSUE IS
BUT IT SHOULD BE THIS IS
BASICALLY A CONSENSUS IS RESULT
OF SPECIAL DISTRICTS AND OTHERS
GETTING TOGETHER. TRY TO DEAL
WITH SOME OF THE CHALLENGES AS
WE CONTINUE TO REFINE AND
REDEVELOP WHAT LASKO MEANS HOW
IT WORKS HOW IT FUNCTIONS AND
WITH THAT. HOW INTERNET OVER TO.
MISS HELLO OF COURSE SELF. PAM
MILLER. THERE ARE A FEW YEARS.
WORK TOGETHER A LOT YES WE HAVE
VERY GOOD GOOD AFTERNON WELCOME
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE PAMELA
MILLER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
AGENCY FORMATION COMMISSION.
REPRESENTING LAUGH BECAUSE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND THE
VERY PROUD SPONSOR OF SB NINE
THIRTY. ARE WE WANT TO THANK AS
SPECIAL BALLOT THANK YOU TO
SENATOR HERTZBERG AYE HE HAS
SPENT MANY LONG YEARS- DABBLING
IN LASKO LAW AND WE'RE SO PROUD.
OF THAT AND WE GOT TO WORK WITH
YOU IN THIS YEAR YOUR LAST YEAR
IN THE LEGISLATURE ON THIS- AS
THE SENATOR MENTIONED THIS- IT
HAS BEEN A LONG TIME COMING THIS
IS A THREE YEAR. OF VERY
COLLABORATIVE PROJECT AND- WE
WANT TO THANK YOUR STAFF SENATOR
HERTZBERG AND MADAM CHAIR YOUR
STAFF IN PARTICULAR AND TIMES.
INTRON DREW THE SHORT STRAW MAN
WITH SEXUALLY A PARTICIPANT A
THREE YEAR PARTICIPANTS IN THE
WORKING GROUP AND HE DID A
WONDERFUL ANALYSIS ON THE BILL
AS WELL. HE ALSO DREW THE SHORT
STRAW AND FOLK OF FACILITATING
THE SUB COMMITTEE OF THE LARGER
WORKING GROUP THAT FOCUSED THEIR
WORK ON THE PROTESTS PROVISION
THRESHOLDS. SO SB NINE THIRTY
EIGHT REPRESENTS AS I SAID A
COLLABORATIVE THREE YEAR EFFORT
TO CLEAN UP CONSOLIDATE AND
CLARIFY EXISTING STATUTORY
PROVISIONS ASSOCIATED WITH
CONSOLIDATIONS AND DISSOLUTIONS
AS WELL AS CODIFY THE CONDITIONS
UNDER WHICH A LAUGH COMEY
INITIATE. DISSOLUTION OF THE
DISTRICT AT THE 25% THRESHOLD.
THE OVERARCHING GOAL OF THESE
CHANGES IS TO ENSURE THAT LAUGH
BECAUSE HAVE THE TOOLS THEY NEED
TO CARRY OUT THE STATUTORY
OBLIGATIONS TO ENSURE ORDERLY
FUNCTIONING LOCAL GOVERNMENT
SERVICES AND TO CREATE GREATER
CONSISTENCY IN THE STATUTE. THE
RESTRUCTURING OF EXISTING
PROTEST PROVISION LANGUAGE
ACTUALLY CREATES A MORE USABLE
STATUTORY FRAMEWORK BY HAVING
ALL OF THE PROTEST CODE SECTIONS
IN ONE MAIN SECTION TO SIMPLIFY
THE READING AND USE OF THAT
STATUTE AND AS THE ANALYSIS-
VERY WELL POINTS OUT. THE NEW
PROTEST PERCENTAGE PROCESS
ADDRESSES A LONG STANDING AND
VERY LARGE DETERRENT FOR LAST
CLOSE TO INITIATE ACTION. EVEN
IF MEANINGFUL EFFICIENCIES IN
THE PROVISION OF SERVICES COULD
BE ACHIEVED OR IF THE DISTRICT
IS FAILING TO MEET ITS STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS. FURTHER IT ADDS A
LEVEL OF ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY FOR BOTH DISTRICTS
AND LAUGH CLOSE BY SPOTLIGHTING
DETERMINATIONS THAT NEED TO BE
MADE IN A MUNICIPAL SERVICE
REVIEW BY LASCO. ALLOWING THE
DISTRICT A TWELVE MONTH MINIMUM
REMEDIATION PERIOD. REQUIRING
THE DISTRICT TO PROVIDE A STATUS
UPDATE REPORT AT THE MIDPOINT OF
THAT REMEDIATION PERIOD AND ADDS
SEVERAL ADDITIONAL LEFT CO
PUBLIC HEARINGS TO THE PROCESS
THEREFORE REALLY ENHANCING THE-
THE TRANSPARENCY. IT'S IMPORTANT
TO KNOW WE WANT TO MAKE VERY
CLEAR THAT THIS PROCESS CAN ONLY
BE USED ù DISSOLUTIONS
INITIATED DISSOLUTIONS. AND ONLY
UNDER THE CONDITIONS THAT ARE
CODIFIED IN FIFTY SIX THREE
SEVEN FIVE POINT ONE. THE 10%%
THRESHOLD FOR LASKO INITIATED
ACTIONS STILL EXISTS WE HAVE NOT
TOUCH THAT AND LAUGH COMMITTEE
CHOOSE TO USE THE 10% THRESHOLD
FOR DISSOLUTIONS IF IT FEELS IT
IS THE BEST USE. GIVEN THE
PARTICULAR CIRCUMSTANCES AND
CONDITIONS THAT EXIST LOS
LOCALLY THIS BILL IS SIMPLY
ANOTHER TOL IN THE LEFT COOK
TOOK AT. WE WANT TO THANK ALL OF
THE STAKEHOLDERS THIS IS AN
EIGHTEEN MEMBER STAKEHOLDER
GROUP. OF LOTS OF- A
REPRESENTATION ALONG THE
SPECTRUM FOR THE TIRELESS
EFFORTS THAT THEY DID OVER THE
THREE YEAR PERIOD TO GET US TO
TODAY. AND AGAIN WE COULDN'T BE
PROUDER OF OUR AUTHOR SO THANK
YOU CENTERS FOR AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
PHONE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. SENATOR HERTZBERG I HAVE
MARKETS THAT BIT WYLER AS THE
SECOND WITNESS. WELCOME SIR.
WHAT HAVE WE HAVEN'T CONFIRMED
IT EXPLICITLY BUT I WOULD BE
HOME WITHOUT A THAT'S A VERY
FAMOUS NAME I JUST WANT TO DO IN
THIS WORLD THAT DETWILER NAMES A
BIG DEAL I'M A RELATIVE THAT WAS
A LOCAL PLANNER IN THE IN
MARYLAND'S TO IT'S REALLY WEIRD-
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- MARKETS THAT WHILE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING
APPROXIMATELY APPROXIMATELY
TWELVE HUNDRED SPECIAL DISTRICTS
PROVIDING CALIFORNIANS WITH A
WIDE ARRAY OF ESSENTIAL LOCAL
SERVICES INCLUDING FIRE
PROTECTION WATER SERVICE PARKS
AND RECREATION AND MORE. CSTA IS
A PROUD SUPPORTER OF SENATE BILL
NINE THIRTY EIGHT A BILL WHICH
WILL CLARIFY AND SIMPLIFY THE
STATUTES RELATING TO THE
CONDUCTING AUTHORITY FOR LAUGH
GOES TO INITIATE SPECIAL
DISTRICT REORGANIZATIONS
IMPORTANTLY SENATE BILL NINE
THIRTY EIGHT ALSO CREATES A NEW
VOTER PROTEST THRESHOLD RELATED
TO LAUGH CO INITIATED SPECIAL
DISTRICTS DISSOLUTIONS OF FOR
THOSE SPECIAL DISTRICTS THAT
MEET SPECIFIED CRITERIA. SENATE
BILL NINE THIRTY EIGHT PROVIDES
LAUGH GOES WITH A POWERFUL NEW
TOOL TO REMEDIATE CONCERNS THAT
MUST BE ADDRESSED IN CONCERT
WITH CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS WHO
DEPEND UPON OWN GOVERNOR AND
OVERSEE THEIR SPECIAL DISTRICT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IT IS
PARTICULARLY FITTING THAT THIS
PARTICULAR LEGISLATION IS BEING
BROUGHT FORTH BY THE SENATE
MAJORITY LEADER EMERITUS
HERTZBERG FOR WHOM THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT REORGANISATION ACT
THE CORTESE KNOCKS HERTZBERG
LOCAL GOVERNMENT REORGANISATION
ACT OF TWO THOUSAND SAY THAT
FIVE TIMES FAST IS NAMED. WE
WOULD LIKE TO THANK SENATOR
HERTZBERG MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND CAL ASCO AS WELL
AS THE OTHER PARTICIPATING
STAKEHOLDERS FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE AND WE
WOULD LIKE TO RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY. IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
JEAN HURST HERE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES. OF CALIFORNIA
AND MY COLLEAGUES ARE THE-
STATE. OF COUNTIES SUPPORT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE HERE
IN THE ROOM. SEE NO ONE MOVING
WILL MOVE ON TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE MATTER
MODERATOR COULD YOU CHECK IF
THEY'RE WITH IS ANYONE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SUPPORT. SENATE
BILL NINE THIRTY EIGHT. THANK
YOU FOR W. AS IN NINE THIRTY
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. AGAIN THAT'S ONE AND THEN
ZERO YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF S. E.
NINE THIRTY EIGHT. AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE THIRTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I DON'T CARE
MEMBERS JASON RIGHT WE
CALIFORNIA CITIES THAT WE ARE
SUPPORTERS MEASURES WELL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT PLEASE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE NO FOR
THIS PARTICULAR TIME VERY GOOD
WE'RE GOING TO NOW MOVE ON TO
THE OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYBODY
IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. SEEING
NO MOVEMENT WILL MOVE ON TO THE
TELEPHONE TELECONFERENCE LINE.
BETTER MODERATE CAN YOU ASK IF
ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO SENATE BILL NINE
THIRTY EIGHT. THANK YOU IF IN
OPPOSITION UP AT EIGHTY NINE
THIRTY EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS ONE
AND THEN ZERO IN OPPOSITION UP
AT E. NINE THIRTY EIGHT. AND WE
DO HAVE ONE IN Q. ONE MOMENT.
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE UP THIRTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE ANDERSON CONCERNED
CITIZEN CITY RANCHERA. I AM IN
OPPOSITION OF SENATE BILL NINE
THREE EIGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
. WE HAVE NO FURTHER OPPOSITION
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE'RE GOING TO BRING
THE BILL BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS. SIGNAL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION AT IT LET ME ACTUALLY LET
ME ASK- SENATOR HERTZBERG TO
CONCLUDE AND- AND TO ADDRESS THE
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS IN THAT IN
THE- BURKE IN. IN THE ANALYSIS
YEAH WE'LL FIND WITH TECHLAND'S
NO PROBLEM AN INCH SO LOOK TO
TURN THE STATE GOVERNMENT'S
COMPLEX. IT'S NOT ALL HEADLINES
THE PUSH IN THE FRONT PAGE OF
THE PAPER THE HEAD OF THE
EVENING NEWS THE HARD WORKERS
THAT THE DEMERS OF WORK THIS
TOOK THE FOR YEARS IT TOOK FOR
US TO DEAL WITH THESE ISSUES.
ZERO FIVE THOUSAND SUBDIVISIONS
OF GOVERNMENT EDITION OF THE
TWELVE HUNDRED SPECIAL DISTRICTS
OVER THOUSAND SCHOOL DISTRICTS
FORTY TWO CITIES FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES INSTEAD A CALIFORNIA.
AND YOU KNOW I WOULD I WOULD
LIKE TO SAY IT'S NOT DEVIL'S IN
THE DETAILS GOD IS IN THE
DETAILS WHEN YOU DO YOUR
HOMEWORK WHEN YOU REALLY DIGGIN
WHEN YOU SPEND THE TIME IT'S
WHEN YOU GET GREAT PUBLIC
POLICY. AND THESE JOBS AND THIS
IS BEEN SOMETHING IN YOU KNOW
CAME TO ME BECAUSE I REPRESENTED
THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY THAT WAS
INVOLVED IN THE SPECIAL
REORGANIZATION- LASKO. GRABBED
MY ATTENTION AND THEN TOOK ME
DOWN THIS ROAD FOR TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY SIX TWENTY SEVEN YEARS
SERVICE BEEN AND THERE'S NO
HEADLINES IS NO BIG POLITICAL
CONTRIBUTIONS THERE'S NO ANY OF
THOSE THINGS LEGISLATORS OF THE
YEAR OF ANYBODY THEY THINK WORKS
TALKING ABOUT THE LAUGH FACTORY
WE TALK ABOUT LASKO. BUT THIS IS
WHAT WE DO IN THIS BUSINESS AND
THAT'S WHY I STAND HERE TO STAND
PROUDLY WITH. ANTON WHO'S A
GREAT INTELLECT AND WORK HARD A
WHOLE HOST OF OTHER PEOPLE
CHRIS- PLEASED TO HOOSICK
COMMITTEE BACK WAY BACK WHEN
WHICH THE REALTORS WITH KRISTA.
HELLO CHRISTOPHER CARLISLE SPENT
FOUR YEARS WORKING ON THIS STUFF
AND JUST TO ACKNOWLEDGE
EVERYBODY IN THE THANK EVERYBODY
BUT THIS IS REALLY HARD WORK AND
I REALLY REALLY APPRECIATE IT
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS. RIVALS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IT'S
RESERVE. AT THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMEND ON THE FLOOR.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL SENATOR. HI
CABALLERO HI SENATOR NIELSEN ALL
RIGHT NIELSEN HI SENATOR DORADO
DORADO HI SENATOR HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG HI SENATOR WIENER.
BORDER ZERO MOTION PASSES FORTY
ZERO WILL HOLD THE ROLE- BRIDGE
OPEN FOR SENATOR WIENER. SENATOR
JOHN THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PATIENCE TO APPRECIATE YOU ARE
YOU ALLOWING SENATOR HERTZBERG
TO JUMP THE JUMP THE LINE WELL I
DON'T KNOW IT TOO BILL I KNOW I
KNOW AND ONE OF MY- WHICH ACTION
GOING ON. THERE THE CENTER I
CAN'T EVEN VOTE ON MY BILL I
GUESS SO NOW HILL WHERE HE'LL BE
HERE. I DO IT'LL IT'S FILE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT SB. TWELVE
FOURTEEN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
FIRST ELECTED THINK THE CHAIR
AND THE STAFF FOR WORKING ON
THIS BILL I THINK WE FOUND A
REALLY STRONG COMPROMISE. THAT
FURTHERS PUBLIC INTEREST WHILE
PROTECTING INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY. SB TWELVE FOURTEEN
STRIKES A BALANCE BETWEEN
PROTECTING ARCHITECTS AND
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY RIGHTS
UNDER THE FEDERAL COPYRIGHT LAW.
AND FACILITATING IMPORTANT
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION IN LOCAL
PLANNING DECISIONS THIS BILL
ESTABLISHES AN APPROPRIATE MODEL
FOR PLANNING DEPARTMENTS TO
SHARE ARCHITECTURAL DRAWINGS
BASED ON THE EXISTING MODEL.
USED BY BUILDING DEPARTMENTS
SPECIFICALLY SB TWELVE FOURTEEN
ALLOWS ACCESS TO FULL DETAILED
ARCHITECTURAL BLUEPRINTS FOR
PHYSICAL INSPECTION BY ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC. BY COMING
INTO THE PLANNING DEPARTMENT
THAT RESTRICTS COPYING THESE
COPYRIGHTED MATERIALS UNLESS THE
OWNER OF THE COPYRIGHT GIVES
PERMISSION. OUTSIDE OF THIS
PHYSICAL INSPECTION PLANNING
DEPARTMENT SHOULD BE ABLE TO
DISPLAY COPYRIGHTED MATERIALS IN
PUBLIC HEARINGS. AND PROVIDE
DRAWINGS TO ANY MEMBER OF THEIR
LEGISLATIVE BODIES AS LONG AS
THE COPYRIGHTED DRYING IS NOT
STORED ONLINE. TO FOR PUBLIC
ACCESS. THIS BILL ALSO ALLOWS
PUBLIC OFFICIALS AND MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC UNLIMITED ACCESS TO
THE LESS DETAILED NON
COPYRIGHTED DRAWINGS. KNOWN AS
SITE PLANS AND MASSING DIAGRAMS.
WE BELIEVE THAT SB TWELVE
FOURTEEN HELPS PROVIDE GUIDANCE
TO LOCAL PLANNING DEPARTMENTS
PROTECTS INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY
RIGHTS OF COPYRIGHT HOLDERS.
ENSURES FULL ACCESS TO THE
PUBLIC AND LOCAL PUBLIC
OFFICIALS. WITH ME TODAY HAVE
MIKE BELOW ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN INSTITUTE OF ARCHITECTS
AND AVAILABLE ON THE PHONE FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IF
NECESSARY OUR KERRY BURNS STEEN
AN ARCHITECT AND STEVEN WEINBERG
AND NOT A COPYRIGHT ATTORNEY.
MANAGER AT LIKE TO TURN IT OVER
TO THE WITNESSES IF THAT IS OKAY
WITH YOU IT'S TERRIFIC WELCOME
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MIGHT PULL OUT ON BEHALF
OF THE AMERICAN INSTITUTE OF
ARCHITECTS CALIFORNIA. AND THANK
YOU TO THE COMMITTEE AND AGAIN
TO ANTON AND THE CHAIR TO
WORKING WITH US ON THIS- JUST A
COUPLE OF POINTS. I'LL BE VERY
THIS IS ALL. A AND CATALOG TO
THE EXIST LAW IN THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY CODE ON- BUILDING
DEPARTMENTS- WE WORKED WITH
DOCTOR THE LEAGUE OF CITIES C.
SACK- THE LEAGUE'S THE DOCUMENT
THE PEOPLE'S BUSINESS IS
PARTICULARLY. INSTRUCTIVE
BECAUSE WE ARE ENTIRELY
CONSISTENT WITH THE WAY THEY
DESCRIBE THE PROCESS FOR THE
BUILDING LAW. AND THEY SAY THE
OFFICIAL COPY OF BUILDING PLANS
MAINTAINED BY LOCAL AGENCIES
BUILDING DEPARTMENT MAY BE
INSPECTED BUT CANNOT BE COPIED
WITHOUT THE LOCAL AGENCY FIRST
REQUESTING THE WRITTEN
PERMISSION. OF THE PROFESSIONAL
WHO SIGNED THE DOCUMENT. AND THE
PROPERTY HOLDER SO WE'VE WE'VE
BUILT THIS OFF OF THE- BUILDING
DEPARTMENT NOW IT IS TRUE THAT
THE FUNCTIONS OF THE BUILDING
DEPARTMENT AND THE PLANNING
DEPARTMENT ARE DIFFERENT. BUT
THIS BALANCE BETWEEN THE
COPYRIGHT PROTECTION UNDER THE
FEDERAL COPYRIGHT ACT IN THE
PUBLIC'S NEED TO GO TO SEE THE
DOCUMENTS AND FIND OUT WHAT'S-
PROPOSED TO A GIRL IN. A TO THE
PROPERTY IS BEING MAINTAINED WE
WITH THE HELP OF THE PUBLIC WILL
HAVE FULL ACCESS ON PREMISES. IN
DURING ANY MEETING OF THE-
PLANNING AGENCY. THE PROBLEM
THOUGH IS THE REMEDY THE
EXISTING REMEDY OF A COPYRIGHT
INFRINGEMENT LAWSUIT IS NOT
GREAT. THE WE SHOULD NEVER
ENCOURAGE LAWSUITS ON THIS KIND
OF THING AFTER ALL THE BUILDING
WILL ALREADY EXIST SO IT'S HARD
TO AND BUILD A BUILDING. SO WE
THINK WE'VE GOT A GOOD BALANCE
HERE AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY. QUESTIONS BUT WOULD ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IS THERE ANYBODY ELSE IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED THAT WOULD
LIKE TO- SUPPORT THE BILL.
SEEING NONE WILL MOVE ON TO DO
YOU HAVE A SECOND WITNESS IF
YOU'D LIKE TO WRITE ARE ONLY FOR
INFORMATION PURPOSES EXPERTS
AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS THAT'S
GREAT ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THAT I APPRECIATE IT I
WILL MOVE ON TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE IS OR
ANYBODY THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
TWELVE FOURTEEN. THANK YOU IF
YOU WEREN'T PART OF. E. TWELFTH
FOURTEEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS ONE AND
THEN IF YOU'RE TO PART OF AT E.
TWELFTH FORTY. AND MEDICARE WE
HAVE NOTS PARTICULAR STUDY VERY
GOOD WILL MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION
IS OR ANYBODY IN ROOM AT TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED THAT WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
. SEEING NO ONE IS THERE ANYBODY
ON THE TELECONFERENCE LANE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. TWELVE
FORTY. THANK YOU FOR IN
OPPOSITION AT EIGHT TWELVE
FOURTEEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE.
BUTTON ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS ONE
NINE ZERO IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION UP AT E. TWELFTH.
FOURTEEN AMATEUR WE HAVE NO
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
VERY GOOD TO ME BRING THE MATTER
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS. THE BILL. THERE
IS A MOTION CENTERED RAZA. YES I
HAVE- COUPLE QUESTIONS TAB HELP
ME UNDERSTAND- WHAT KIND OF
STOOD OUT FOR ME IS. THAT IT
DOESN'T APPEAR FROM THE ANALYSIS
IS THAT THERE'S A BIG PROBLEM-
AND SO I'M TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
ONE ONE EXAMPLE WAS GIVEN- AND
LITTLE REMARKS THE COMMENTS ARE
MADE OF YEAH WE LOOKING FOR A
PROBLEM HERE- AND THERE'S NOT
REALLY A PROBLEM SO WE'RE
LOOKING WHAT ARE WE LOOKING TO
SOLVE WHAT IS REALLY AT STAKE
HERE OR NOT I KNOW WHAT'S AT
STAKE AS FAR AS THE PUBLIC RIGHT
WE WANT THE PUBLIC TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THESE DOCUMENTS
SO. WHAT'S THE PROBLEM I YOU
KNOW I THINK I AGREE WITH YOU
IT'S PROBABLY A MINOR PROBLEM
AND IT'S LIMITED- YOU KNOW
TOWARD X. WHERE THEIR EXPOSURE
IS ACROSS THE STATE ONE OF THE
THINGS WHEN I FIRST GOT ALL OF
MY BROTHER'S A HOME BUILDER MY
DAD'S A HOME BUILDER WHEN I
FIRST GOT ELECTED TO THE CITY
COUNCIL IN TWO THOUSAND TWO AND-
THIS WAS ALWAYS PECULIAR TO ME
THAT. THESE PLANS WOULD COME IN
ORDER THE CITY COUNCIL AND-
EVERYTHING WAS THERE. YOU KNOW-
THAT THE ARCHITECTS HAVE BEEN
PAID TO DO AND- PUT ON PAPER AND
AVAILABLE TO YOU KNOW. A DOWN TO
THE VERY DETAIL- FOR THE
PUBLIC'S REVIEW AND THEN. I
ALWAYS KIND OF HAD THIS CONCEPT
OF. IT THAT'S EXPOSED YOU KNOW
FOR THEIR COMPETITION TO HAVE
ACCESS TO IT SO I THOUGHT THAT
WAS PECULIAR AND THEN. YOU KNOW.
OBVIOUSLY DIDN'T THINK MUCH OF
IT AFTER THAT BUT THIS CAME TO
US THIS YEAR. I THINK THE- IT IS
LIMITED THE EXPOSURE IS. LIMITED
TO IF YOU KNOW IF YOU
PROFESSIONALS IN THE STATE BUT-
I THINK AS- AS POLICYMAKERS- WE
WANT TO ALIGN. THE STATE POLICY
WITH THE FEDERAL- POLICY TO
PREVENT THESE LAWSUITS- THAT
DOES EXTEND. IT JUST.GREAT A
SITUATION WHERE WE'RE PUTTING
THINGS INTO THE COURTS I THINK
THAT CAN BE SOLVED HERE TODAY-
IN ADDITION TO THAT IF MR BELOW
HAS SOME ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
SAID. LIKE FOR HIM TO ADD ON TO
THAT THROUGH CHAIR VENTURE. YES
OKAY THANK YOU I'M SORRY I THINK
IT'S A VERY FAIR QUESTION
SENATOR DORADO THE ASSOCIATION
HAS PASSED FOR EXAMPLES WE'VE
HAD PEOPLE FRANKLY KIND OF
SHEEPISHLY ADMIT YES WE HAVE
DONE THAT OURSELVES WHERE WHERE
OF CONTRACTORS HAVING DONE IT
IT'S KIND OF A SOMETHING THAT NO
ONE WANTS TO TALK ABOUT AND YOU
DON'T WANT TO NAME NAMES. BUT IF
YOU TAKE THE ARCHITECT'S
DRAWINGS FOR DESIGN REFERENCE
AND THEY ADMIT THAT IT'S
HAPPENING- THAT IS A COPYRIGHT
VIOLATION AND IF THEY'RE JUST
LEFT OUT IN THE OPEN PERMANENTLY
THEN WE'RE FACILITATING THAT SO
WE'D LIKE TO. YOU KNOW GET AHEAD
OF IT. LAY OUT THE RULES
CONSISTENT WITH THE BUILDING
DEPARTMENT AND PREVENT LAWSUITS
THAT. ANY OTHER QUESTION CENTER
DRAWS A. YEAH I THOUGHT SO IT
MAYBE IT IS RIGHT I DON'T SEE
THAT THERE'S A PROBLEM OTHER
THAN MAYBE SOMETIME IN THE
FUTURE KIND OF SITUATION SO. WHY
DO WE WANT TO TAKE THAT THE
SIDES YOU KNOW WITH THE PUBLIC
HAVING ACCESS WHEN IT HASN'T
BEEN A PROBLEM I AND I THINK TO
MR BALOCH POINT THERE HAVE BEEN
SITUATIONS WHERE AT HAS ALREADY
HAPPENED AND AGAIN. A SMALL AND
VERY LIMITED- SO IT IS A SMALL
PROBLEM IN A VERY LIMITED
PROBLEM THAT WE'RE TRYING TO FIX
HERE TODAY. YES SENATOR ALSO IF
I COULD IF I COULD- I MEAN I HAD
THE SAME ISSUE IT WHEN WE SAT
DOWN HAD A CONVERSATION I THINK
WHAT WAS. WHAT CONVINCED ME IS
THAT- AND I SAT ON A PLANNING
COMMISSION AND ALSO ON THE CITY
COUNCIL. AND I WAS CONCERNED
ABOUT THOSE BOARDS AND BODIES
HAVING THE DOCUMENTS THEY NEED
TO BE ABLE TO ANALYZE NEW
PROJECTS IN THEIR IN THEIR
COMMUNITY. AND THERE'S A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN HAVING THE
DETAILED. PLANNING DOCUMENTS
THAT CONSTRUCTION DOCUMENTS IF
YOU WILL- THAT TELL YOU- DOWN TO
THE TO THE- TO THE INCH LEVEL
WHAT WHAT SHE NEEDS TO GO WHERE
RIGHT- IT THERE IS THERE'S A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THAT AND SITE
PLANS AND MASSING DOT DIAGRAMS
MASSING DIAGRAMS TO SHOW YOU HOW
BIG THE BUILDING IS AND WHAT IT%
LOOKS LIKE. AND THAT THE SITE
PLANS TELL YOU THE SET BACKS AND
ALL THAT KINDA STUFF IN OTHER
WORDS YOU DON'T NEED THE LEVEL
OF DETAIL THAT THE- BUILDING
DOCUMENTS. WOULD GIVE YOU. BUT
IF YOU WANT THAT YOU CAN GO INTO
THE INTO THE- INTO THE BUILDING.
OFFICIALS OFFICE TAKE A LOOK AT
IT. AND IF THE ARCHITECTS GIVES
APPROVAL YOU CAN GET A COPY OF
IT. AS A MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC SO
THE IDEA IS THAT YOU GET. YOU
GET WHAT YOU NEED TO BE ABLE TO
TELL WHAT THE BUILDINGS GOING TO
LOOK LIKE- ALL OF THAT IS
AVAILABLE BUT THAT CONSTRUCTION
DOCUMENTS ARE THOSE ARE WITH
WEATHER BEING AND IF I. IF I'VE
GOT IT WRONG PLEASE. PLEASE
INVENT AND FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
IF IT'S ALREADY FEDERAL LINE
IT'S PREEMPTED IN YOU CAN'T GET
THOSE YOU'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO BE
GETTING THOSE DOCUMENTS THEN- WE
JUST NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
RIGHT HANDLES WITH THE LEFT HAND
IS DOING AND MAKE IT VERY CLEAR.
IN IN- IN THE CODE AND THAT'S
WHAT THIS THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL
IS ABOUT SO FOR THAT REASON I'M
GOING TO SUPPORT IT. SUPPORTED
TODAY- AND- THE MOTION HAS BEEN
MADE. THAT SOMEBODY MAKE MARGIN
OKAY. CENTER HERTZBERG MADE THE
MOTION. ARE THERE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. BUT I GUESS NOW.
WANNA MAKE THE COMMENT I'M- I'M
UNCOMFORTABLE BECAUSE I DON'T
SEE. AN IMBALANCE. IN TERMS OF
WHAT'S- WHAT WE'RE ASKING FOR
AND WHAT THE PROBLEM IS. I WILL
TODAY SUPPORT BUT I. NEED TO
HAVE MORE CONVERSATION TO MAKE A
REAL COMMITMENT THANK YOU. WE
WILL HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS
VERY GOOD IT AND IT MIGHT BE
GOOD JUST TO TAKE THE DIFFERENT
DOCUMENTS SO YOU GET THIS AT A
CHANCE TO SEE WHAT THE
DIFFERENCES AND- WHAT WHAT
YOU'RE WHAT WE'RE DOING WITH
THIS BILL SO I DO APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS AND- THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED BUT FIRST TO BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SENATOR COLORADO HI CABALLERO I
SENATOR NIELSEN HI NIELSEN HI
SENATOR DORADO ZERO ZERO HI
SENATOR HERTZBERG BY HERTZBERG
HI SENATOR WIENER. WIENER HI.
FIVE ZERO. THE BILL IS OUT FIVE
TWO ZERO MAKE MANAGER THANK YOU
AND- CENTERS PERCENT. ON THE FOR
EXAMPLE. WITH.
YEAH THIS IS OKAY WITH I WANNA
MAKE SURE SHE'S OKAY WILL MOVE
ON TO ITEM FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE
WHICH IS S. B. THIRTEEN TWELVE
BY SENATOR OCHO BUG. WELCOME AND
I WANNA THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
. ALLOWING SENATOR HERTZBERG TO
JUMP IN FRONT OF YOU ABSOLUTELY
HE'S ALWAYS A GENTLEMAN WHY
WOULDN'T WE- OF THE THIRTY FIRST
TIME IN THIS COMMITTEE SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND WELCOME. THANK
YOU. VERY VERY EXCITED TO BE
HERE- MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I
AM PLEASED TO PRESENT SENATE
BILL THIRTEEN TWELVE THANK YOU
TO THE CHAIR IN THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH ME ON
THIS MEASURE AND WILL BE TAKING
THE AMENDMENTS. AS PROPOSED. SB
THIRTEEN TWELVE SIX TO HARMONIZE
CALIFORNIA'S MARKETPLACE
FACILITATOR LAW WITH CURRENT
PRACTICE BY CLEARLY IDENTIFYING
THE MARKETPLACE SELLER AS A TAX
RESPONSIBLE PARTY AND CAR RENTAL
TRANSACTIONS. FACILITATED BY AN
ONLINE TRAVEL COMPANY. MANY
STATES HAVE ADOPTED MARKETPLACE
FACILITATOR LAWS GOVERNING SALES
USE TAX REMITTANCE OBLIGATIONS
WHEN BUSINESS TAXPAYERS PARTNER
TO SELL GOODS AND OR SERVICES
THROUGH THIRD PARTY.
INTERMEDIARIES CAR RENTAL
CUSTOMERS ALSO FREQUENTLY MODIFY
THEIR BOOKINGS AT THE COUNTER
WHICH CAN DRASTICALLY CHANGE THE
TAXES AND OTHER CHARGES THAT
APPLY TO THE RENTAL. THESE
RESULT IN THERE BEING MULTIPLE
RETAILERS FOR DIFFERENT
COMPONENTS OF A SINGLE CAR
RENTAL BOOKING. FURTHER
COMPLICATING THE TAX COLLECTION
AND REMITTANCE REQUIREMENTS
UNDER THE NEW MARKETPLACE
COMPANIES DO NOT HAVE ACCESS TO
COMPLETE AND SUFFICIENT
INFORMATION NECESSARY TO
ACCURATELY COMPUTE THE TAXES DUE
FOR CAR RENTAL BOOKINGS. RENTAL
CAR COMPANIES HAVE PHYSICAL
PRESENCE IN CALIFORNIA AND THE
TRANSACTION IS PRIMARILY TAKING
PLACE IN THE RENTAL CAR
COMPANY'S PHYSICAL LOCATION.
THESE COMPANIES HAVE DEEP
INDUSTRY KNOWLEDGE COMPLETE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE
TRANSACTION AND ARE UNDER
PERPETUAL AUDIT WITH THE CD TFA
. SHIFTING THE TAX
RESPONSIBILITY TO PLATFORMS WHO
WILL WHO ARE ILL EQUIPPED TO
NAVIGATE COMPLEXITIES ONLY LEADS
TO CONFUSION FOR THE PLATFORM.
THE RENTAL CAR COMPANY AND THE
CD TFA ODD AUDITORS. RENTAL CAR
COMPANIES ARE ALREADY REMITTING
TAX AND THESE TRANSACTIONS AND
ARE UNDER CONTINUOUS AUDIT BY
THE CD TFA. SB THIRTEEN TWELVE
WILL CLEARLY IDENTIFY THE
MARKETPLACE SELLER AS A TAX
RESPONSIBLE PARTY IN CAR RENTAL
TRANSACTIONS. THROUGH CREATING
MORE TRANSPARENCY IN THE PROCESS
CAR RENTAL GROUPS AS WELL AS THE
STATE AUDITOR'S WILL OPERATE
WITHIN A MORE CLEARLY DEFINED
TAXATION SYSTEM. JOINING ME TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT AND TO HELP
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
IS ALYSSA STINSON AND STEPHANIE
GILL FEATHER ON BEHALF OF OUR
BILL SPONSOR EXPEDIA GROUP. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
ABOUT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH CALL
YOUR FIRST. WITNESS BOTH OF THEM
I UNDERSTAND ARE ON THE PHONE.
SO WE'LL START WITH ALYSSA
STINSON. MADAME MODERATOR IF YOU
COULD OPEN HER LINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM SHERIFF THE
NUMBER AND MY NAME IS ALEXIS
THEN AND I HAD THE GREAT
GROUP'S REGIONAL GOVERNOR
MANAGER THE GREAT. CALIFORNIA
THE FAMILY OF TRY BRANDS
INCLUDING EXPEDIA DOT COM ORBITZ
HOTWIRE TRAVELOCITY ANYMORE. I'M
HERE TODAY TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT SENATE BILL THIRTEEN
TWELVE. I'VE BEEN UNDER
DEVELOPMENT AND I THINK THIRTEEN
TWELVE WILL SIMPLY HARMONIZED
CALIFORNIA EIGHT O'CLOCK I DON'T
THINK IT LOT WITH CURRENT
PRACTICE. I CLEARLY IDENTIFY THE
FACT OF PARTY FOR ALL CAR RENTAL
TRAIN. FACILITATED BY ONLINE
TRAVEL COMPANY. I'VE BEEN
UNEXPECTED RESULT OF THE MARKETS
THAT FACILITATE OUR LAW- POINT
EIGHTEEN. THAT THESE UNIQUE
SITUATION BOTH- ONLINE TRAVEL
COMPANIES AND CAR RENTAL
COMPANIES ARE CONSIDERED THE
FACT ON A PARTY FOR THE FANS
TRANSACTION. IF FIGHT YOUNG MY
TRAVEL COMPANY NOT HAVING ACCESS
TO THE INFORMATION THAT VARY
ADEQUATELY REMAIN. ACT I'M NOT
LOOKING. ALSO IT IS ADVANCED AND
FISH FIVE SIX FAR ABOUT THE
TRAVEL. FROM ARM FROM THEIR
MARKET. ARE LOCKED. MAKING
RENTAL CAR. AND INCLUDING
MISSOURI AND- IN WASHINGTON NEW
YORK SPECIFICALLY. OUR TEAM
WORKS AT THE STATE LEGISLATURE
TO EXPLAIN THE COMPLEX THAT THE
ISSUE AND THE ULTIMATELY.
SIMILAR TENSIONS ONE BEING CAN.
OUT THAT WOULD BE BECAUSE OF THE
COMP OF RENTAL CUSTOMERS BECAUSE
MODIFYING THEIR **** ACCOUNT. MY
UNINSTALL COMPANIES LIKE A GROUP
HAVE NO KNOWLEDGE OF THE CHANGES
ARE UNABLE TO THE ACCOUNT AND
THEN IMPROPERLY ACTIVE. WHICH
RESULTS IN BEING YOU CAN. VERY
DIFFERENT COMPOUND- OF THINGS
ALL RIGHT FOR CAR PARKING SIX
FIVE I'M NOT. COMPLEXITY FOR THE
STATE. OF OUR COMPANY AND THAT'S
- I THIS BILL WOULD ACT. REMOVE
THE- ONLINE TRAVEL. FROM
LIABILITY LEAVE OR REMAIN IN THE
RENTAL COMPANY FOR ALREADY IF
ALL OF PERMITTING FACT AND YOU A
WITH NO ISSUE OF MATERIAL FACT
LEAKAGE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY. IN AMES AND FEDERATION OF
SB THIRTEEN FILED WITH ME ON THE
LINE AS YOU GROUP'S RECORD FACT
ACTUALLY GO EITHER ANSWER ANY.
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE YEAH.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IS THERE ANY IN TO TWO HUNDRED
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF. THIS BILL. SEEING NO
MOVEMENT WILL MOVE ON TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE BETTER
MODERATOR CAN YOU Q. OF AYBODY
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. THIRTEEN TWELVE
. THANK YOU. PARK AT EIGHT
THIRTEEN TWELVE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT
ONE AND THEN THEY'RE UP THERE IN
PART AT THE THIRTEENTH TWELVE.
AND MEDICARE WE HAVE NO ONE IN
SUPPORT OF Q. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION
IS THERE ANYBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF
THIRTEEN TWELVE. SEEING NO
MOVEMENT WILL GO ON TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE BETTER
MODERATOR CAN YOU- ASK IF
THERE'S ANYONE THAT WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU IF YOU'RE IN A- OF AT THE-
THIRTEEN TWELVE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT
ONE AND THEN ZERO OPPOSITION UP
AT E. THIRTEEN TWELVE. YEAH
MEDICARE WE HAVE NO OPPOSITION
IN Q. VERY GOOD WILL BRING THE-
THE MATTER BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS THAT- COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE CENTER DRIVE
SOUTH. YEAH- THE PART OF THE
PROBLEM WITH OF THESE NEW
INNOVATIVE WAYS OF. DOING THINGS
ONLINE IS IT CREATES THESE
ISSUES. AND THEY WERE SORT OF
STUCK TRYING TO FIGURE IT OUT
AND SORTED OUT- SO THAT'S JUST
THE FIRST THING THAT ALWAYS HITS
ME AS- IT MOVES FORWARD. EXPEDIA
OTHER COMPANIES I USE- WHATEVER
WE'LL USE THEM BUT- IT CREATES
SOME PROBLEMS HERE AND THEN WE
HAVE TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO. MAKE
SURE IT DOESN'T CAUSE- ISSUES OF
I UNDERSTAND WITH REGARDS TO THE
STATE THAT THE COLLECTION OF
TAXES WILL NOT BE. BUT IMPACTED.
OKAY IF ANYTHING PLAYING THAT
SURE IF ANYTHING I THINK IT WILL
BE MORE ACCURATE BECAUSE
SOMETIMES WHEN THERE'S CHANGES.
THE PLATFORMS ARE NOT AWARE OF
THESE CHANGES SO THEY CAN'T AND
EVERY STATE BEING DIFFERENT WITH
THE CHANGES FROM THE CONSUMER
MIGHT CREATE SOME DISCREPANCIES
AND WHAT IS COLLECTED WHAT IS
NOT WHEN YOU HAVE SOMEBODY
DIRECTLY. IN STATE THAT KNOWS
WHAT THE CURRENT AMOUNTS ARE IN
THE KNOW WHAT THE CHANGES ARE TO
THE LOCAL BOOKINGS THEN THEY CAN
HAVE A MORE ACCURATE COLLECTION
OF THE TAXES AND IN THIS CASE SO
I THINK IF ANYTHING IT ALLOWS
FOR MORE TRANSPARENCY MORE
ACCURACY IN ASK RECEIVING NOT US
BUT I'M- THE- CITY TFA.
RECEIVING THE- THE TAXES THAT
ARE NECESSARY- I DIDN'T SEE I
DIDN'T SEE- ANY KIND OF-
COMMENTS FROM THE CAR RENTAL
COMPANIES CAN YOU TELL ME SURE
THEY HAVE A POSITION- SO NO
OPPOSITION WE'VE ACTUALLY WE HAD
ACTIVE CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
DIFFERENT- CAR RENTAL COMPANIES
THERE'S AVIS HERTZ- THERE WAS
ONE OTHER A COMPANY THAT WE
ACTUALLY GOT WAS A WE HAD A
VARIETY OF- RENTAL COMPANY
RENTAL CAR COMPANIES THAT WE
ACTUALLY ENGAGE WITH TO MAKE
SURE AND THEY ACTUALLY WERE VERY
ACTIVE AND ENGAGED IN DRAFTING
THE LANGUAGE FOR THE BILL. SO
WHAT IS THERE IS THERE OFFICIAL
POSITION IN SUPPORT OR IS IT
WELL IF WHAT IS THERE I AM GOING
TO ASSUME THAT IT IS IN SUPPORT
BECAUSE THEY WERE IT IT OUT AT
THE TABLE DRAFTING THE LANGUAGE-
IS. ANYONE ON ON THE PHONE WOULD
LIKE TO. LIVE WITH A LITTLE BIT
MORE THAN THAT BUT- I'M GOING TO
ASSUME THAT IF YOU'RE ENGAGED IN
THE CONVERSATIONS AND YOU ARE
HELPING DRAFT THE LANGUAGE THA
THEY WILL BE AN ABSOLUTE
SUPPORT. AND THERE IS NO FORMAL
OPPOSITION OR- NO EXPRESSED.
OPPOSITION AS OUR OFFICE- AS I
KNOW IT TO BE OKAY. WELL I WILL
SUPPORT TODAY BUT I HOPE TO HEAR
MORE FORMALLY FROM THEM AND- NOT
THROUGH YOU. YOU KNOW ASSUMING
BECAUSE- I'VE BEEN IN SITUATIONS
WHERE- AND STAKEHOLDERS ARE AT
AT THE TABLE BUT DON'T END UP
SUPPORTING JUST BECAUSE THEY
WERE THERE SO GOOD POINT I WILL
MAKE SURE THAT I RELATE THE
IMPORTANCE OF DRAFTING A FORMAL
LETTER- GREAT SO I WILL. TAKE
THAT BACK. ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS. IS THERE A MOTION.
MOVE VERY GOOD. MOTION IS BEEN
MADE TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT
FIRST AMEND AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
JUST TO BE CLEAR- YOU WERE IN
AGREEMENT TO DELETE- SECTION TWO
FROM THE BILL YES MA'AM OKAY
VERY GOOD- PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE PROBLEM ONE I. SENATOR
NELSON I NIELSEN AYE SENATOR
DORADO I DO ALSO HI SENATOR
HERTZBERG. SENATOR WIENER WIENER
HI THANK YOU FOR DESERVE THE
BILL PASSES FORTY ZERO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- HERE IN THE NEXT ITEM
IS YOURS AS WELL WHICH IS S. B.
THIRTEEN FORTY FIVE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK THE CHAIR THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT AND TEN. OF FOR YOUR
DILIGENT WORK IN THIS BILL I'M
HAPPY TO ACCEPT ALL THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN
THE ANALYSIS SB THIRTEEN FORTY
FIVE WILL FULLY INTEGRATE ALL
UNDERGROUND UTILITIES INTO THE
CALL BEFORE YOU DIG LAW. BY
ADDING CALTRANS AS A UTILITY
OPERATOR UNDER THE STATE'S TO
REGIONAL SUB SERVICE. YOU TOO
LEAN OF NOTIFICATION CENTERS AND
BY ADDING NON PRESSURIZED SEWER
LINES AND STOM DRAINS THE
DEFINITION OF SUB SERVICE
INSTALLATION. CURRENT LAW AN
INDIVIDUAL OR AN ENTITY PLANNING
TO PERFORM AN EXCAVATION TO
INFORM ONE OR OF TWO REGIONAL
NOTIFICATION CENTER SO OPERATORS
OF ANY UNDERGROUND UTILITIES IN
THE AREA CAN MARK THEIR
FACILITIES. THE LAW S INTENDED
TO PREVENT EXCAVATORS FROM
DAMAGING UNDERGROUND UTILITIES
AND TO PROTECT EXCAVATORS AND
THE PUBLIC FROM HEALTH AND
SAFETY RISKS ONCE IN THIS
COMPUTER CONTACT A REGIONAL
NOTIFICATION CENTER COLLECTIVELY
REFERRED TO AS EIGHT ONE ONE.
ONE OR MORE UTILITY OPERATORS
MARK THE LOCATION OF THEIR
UNDERGRAD FACILITIES WITH PAINT
FLAGS OR BY OTHER MEANS. IT IS
THEN THE ESCALATORS
RESPONSIBILITY TO DETERMINE THE
EXACT LOCATION OF THE FACILITIES
AND AVOID DAMAGING THEM. EIGHT
TWO THOUSAND AND FOURTEEN
FEDERAL REPORT PRODUCED BY THE
PIPELINE AND HAZARDOUS MATERIALS
SAFETY ADMINISTRATION GAVE
CALIFORNIA A LOWER GRADE BECAUSE
OF THE TWO NOTIFICATION CENTERS
DO NOT CURRENTLY INCLUDE
CALTRANS. WHO OPERATE RELATIVELY
FEW SUB SERVICE INFRASTRUCTURES
WITHIN THE ADJACENT. TO ITS
RIGHT OF WAYS THE REPORT ALSO
CITED THE EXCLUSION OF NON
PRESSURIZED SEWER LINES OR STORM
DRAINS AS A REASON FOR THE LOWER
ASSESSMENT. THIS BILL SEEKS TO
REMEDY BOTH OF THESE
DEFICIENCIES ADDITIONALLY THE
CALIFORNIA COMMON GROUND
ALLEGIANCE ALLIANCE I'M SORRY
ALLIANCE THE STATE CHAPTER OF A
NATIONAL ORGANIZATION DEDICATED
TO EXCAVATION SAFETY CONSISTING
OF UTILITIES UTILITY LOCATING
COMPANIES AND EXCAVATORS.
IDENTIFIED SEVERAL ADDITIONAL
SHORTCOMINGS WITH CALIFORNIA'S
EIGHT ONE ONE LAW AND THOSE ARE
THE FUNCTIONAL AND KILLER FINE
ISSUES ADDRESSED IN THIS BILL. I
WANTED TO THANK THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION SANITATION AGENCIES
FOR THE INFORMATIVE
CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD SO FAR.
WELL WE HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO
REACH A COMPROMISE YET I'M OPEN
TO FURTHER CONVERSATIONS JOINING
ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT AND TO
HELP TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS IS TODD BLUMSTEIN ON
BEHALF OF THE SPONSOR THE
UNDERGROUND SERVICE ALERT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. THE ALERT
AND JAMES WINGATEON BEHALF OF
USA NORTH. EIGHT ONE ONE- AGAIN
WELCOME THANK YOU THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I ALSO LIKE TO
RECOGNISE ANTON IN THE COMMITTEE
FOR THEIR THOUGHTFUL ENGAGEMENT
ON THIS BILL- TAUGHT BLUESTEIN
BEHALF THE SPONSOR THE
UNDERGROUND SERVICE ALERT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA- DEKLERK'S.
I ALSO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION AS WELL SB THIRTEEN
FORTY FIVE AMENDS THE CALL
BEFORE YOU DIG LAW IS A FREE
SERVICE FOR ANY PERSON OR
COMPANY. PLANNING TO DIG INTO
THE GROUND THE SERVICE REQUIRES
MOST UTILITIES TO LOCATE AND
MARK BEER UNDERGROUND UTILITIES
IN ORDER FOR THE PERSON OR
COMPANY EXCAVATING TO DO SO
SAFELY AROUND POTENTIALLY
DANGEROUS UNDERGROUND UTILITIES.
ARTICULAR DILLER REPORTS A
SUCCESS RATE OF 99% AND AVOIDING
UNDERGROUND UTILITIES FOR THOSE
THAT USE THE SERVICE. SB
THIRTEEN FORTY FIVE ORIGINATED
FROM AN INDUSTRY WORKING GROUP
CALLED CARGA THE CALIFORNIA
REGIONAL COMMON GROUND IT'S
ALREADY COURTED CONSISTS OF
UTILITY COMPANIES EXCAVATORS AND
COMPANIES THAT LOCATE AND MARK
UNDERGROUND UTILITIES. SB
THIRTEEN FORTY FIVE AS PRIMARILY
A TECHNICAL BILL DEVELOP BY
CARTER. CARGAS INDUSTRY
REPRESENTATIVES. THE BILL DOES
EXPAND THE SERVICE TO GRAVITY
DRIVEN SEWER LINES AND OTHER
SIMILAR INFRASTRUCTURE WE HAVE
MET WITH THE SEWER DISTRICT'S
REPRESENTATIVE AND UNDERSTAND
THEIR CONCERN WITH COSTS AND
THEIR ABILITY TO. ACCURATELY
LOCATE THEIR INFRASTRUCTURE- THE
SIMPLE FACT IS THE CALIFORNIA
WHEN COMPARED TO OTHER WESTERN
STATES IS AN OUT LIAR WHEN IT
COMES TO EXEMPTING UNDERGROUND
UTILITIES FROM THE CALL BEFORE
YOU DIG LAW. IT IS THE ONLY
WESTERN STATE WITH STATUTORY
EXEMPTIONS FOR SEWER STORM
DRAINS AND OTHER GRAVITY DRIVEN
UNDERGROUND LINES I WE'VE
REVIEWED THE STATUTES IN
WASHINGTON OREGON ARIZONA NEVADA
UTAH AND IDAHO. AND THEY DO NOT
PROVIDE ANY EXEMPTIONS FOR
GRAVITY DRIVEN SEWER LINES A
DEALER CARGO AND SCCA ALL
BELIEVE EXCAVATORS SHOULD KNOW
THE LOCATION OF POTENTIALLY
DANGEROUS INFRASTRUCTURE BELOW
THAT BELOW THE SURFACE- AND
BEFORE THEY BEGIN EXCAVATING. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MR
WINGATE- I BELIEVE HE IS ON THE
PHONE- SO- MADAM MODERATOR IF
YOU COULD OPEN. THE PHONE FOR MR
WINGATE. MADAME MODERATOR YOU
WITH US WE GET YOU KNOW I OF THE
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JAMES WINGATE I'M FROM
UNDERGROUND SERVICE ALERT OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA NEVADA WHICH
IS THE EIGHT ONE ONE CONTACT
CENTER THAT HANDLES NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. YOU ALREADY IN MY
LETTER OF SUPPORT IN YOUR PACKET
FIREWALL FREE THAT DAY. BUT
YOU'VE GOT A LONG LIST BUILDING
I KNOW YOU'RE READY FOR LUNCH
THIS ONE IS THE MOST IMPORTANT
ON YOUR AGENDA TODAY. BECAUSE
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE IT
OPPOSITION FROM THE TO OUR
COMPANY. BUT WHAT HAPPENED IS
FOR DECADES THE SEWER COMPANIES
HAVE BEEN EXEMPTED FROM
PARTICIPATING AS A UTILITY
OPERATOR LIKE THE REST OF THE
UTILITY OPERATORS WHEN IT COMES
TO MARKING. THEIR FACILITIES IN
THE FIELD THEY CAN BE DAMAGED
DURING EXCAVATION. SO THIS BILL
IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO GET
THEM TO PARTICIPATE BECAUSE
DAMAGE IS TO HAPPEN TO THEIR
FACILITY EVEN THOUGH THEY ARE
DEEPER. THAN OTHER UTILITIES AS
A GENERAL RULE BUT THEIR
FACILITIES TO GET DAMAGED WE
HAVE TEN OF THOUSANDS OF UTILITY
LINE DAMAGES IN CALIFORNIA EVERY
YEAR YOU HEARD THAT CORRECTLY
TEN OF THOUSANDS. SO THE TOUR
COMPANIES ARE GOING TO ARGUE
THAT IT COSTS THEM MONEY AND
TIME AND LABOR MARKET-
FACILITIES IN THE FIELD THAT IS
CORRECT IT WILL. BUT EVERY OTHER
UTILITY OPERATOR ALREADY DOES
THAT IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THE
UTILITY- FOR THE SEWER INDUSTRY.
I JOIN AND PARTICIPATE IN THE
DAMAGE PREVENTION PROCESS ALL
UTILITY OPERATORS HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO. WHEN THEY PUT
THE PHILLIES IN THE GROUND TO
KEEP TRACK OF THEM AND TO
PROACTIVELY PROTECT THEM BY
MARKING THEM. AND PARTICIPATING
TO HELP ACTIVATORS DODD AND WHEN
THEY'RE WORKING IN THE FIELD
THIS BILL WILL REQUIRED TO OUR
COMPANIES TO DO THE THING. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY.
IS ANYONE ELSE IN THE ROOM AT
TWO TWO. AT TWENTY TWO HIGH.
THAT WOULD LIKE TO. SEEING NO
MOVEMENT WILL MOVE ON TO THE-
TELECONFERENCE LINE. MATTER
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD OPEN TO
THE PUBLIC. THEY WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF. THIRTEEN
FORTY FIVE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIRTEEN FORTY FIVE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
. AGAIN THAT IS IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. THIRTEEN FORTY FIVE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE THE SIXTY NINE
YEAR LINE OF THE OPEN. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MET COMMITTEE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA NEVADA
CONFERENCE OF OPERATING
ENGINEERS HERE DAN STRONG
SUPPORT WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS FOR
THEIR HARD WORK ON THIS BILL
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXT PLEASE. THANK
YOU MEDICARE WE HAVE NO FOR THIS
IMPORTANT YOU AT THE TIME. VERY
GOOD WE HAVE TO. LEAVE THE LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESSES MY DILLON
WHO IS IN PERSON AND JASON I
CARDS SO WE CAN START WITH WITH
MY DAILY. WELCOME THANK YOU
MADAM MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MY
DILLON REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION SANITATION AGENCIES
ALL THE MAJOR WASTE WATER
AGENCIES IN THE STATE- AS YOU
ANALYSIS MENTIONS IN SENATOR HAS
MENTIONED. THAT FOR OVER THIRTY
YEARS THE OWNERS AND OPERATORS
OF NON PRESSURIZED SEWER LINES
AND STORM DRAINS HAVE BEEN
EXEMPT. FROM HAVING TO A MARK
THESE LINES UP PRIOR TO AN
EXCAVATION- THE REASON THAT THE
LINES ARE TYPICALLY FIVE TO
TWENTY FEET DEEP. AND IF IT
WHICH IS RARE POSE NO DANGER TO
THE EXCAVATOR OR THE PUBLIC THEM
MR BLUM STYLE MENTION POTENTIAL
DANGER BUT OUR FOLKS HAVE REALLY
NOT SEEN. ANY DANGER YES A
PROBLEM BUT NEVER A DANGER
CASSAR WAS EXTENSIVELY INVOLVED
IN THE TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN LEGISLATION BY SENATOR
JERRY HILL AND THEN THAT.
SITUATION WE WERE SUCCESSFUL IN
GETTING THE EXEMPTION CONTINUED-
THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE AND SENATORS
MENTION THAT- THE TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN FEDERAL REPORT PRODUCED
BY THE PIPELINE AND HAZARDOUS
MATERIALS SAFETY ADMINISTRATION.
CALIFORNIA WAS GIVEN THE LOWER
ASSESSMENT- BECAUSE OF THE
EXCLUSION OF THE NON PRESSURE
SEWER LINES AND STORM DRAINS WE
DO NOT RECALL THE ISSUE OF
CALIFORNIA GETTING A LOWER
ASSESSMENT EVER SURFACING DURING
THE DEVELOPMENT OF SENATOR HILLS
LEGISLATION IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN. YESTERDAY ONE
OF OUR AGENCIES- FORWARDED A
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY ONE LETTER
FROM THE US DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION PIPELINE AND
HAZARDOUS MATERIALS SAFETY
ADMINISTRATION- TO TONY MARINO
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
SAFETY BOARD. THE LETTER SAYS
BASED ON A TWENTY TWENTY
VALUATION AND I QUOTE. IT'S BEEN
MADE THAT CALIFORNIA- EXCAVATION
DAMAGE. LAW IS ADEQUATE THE
LITTLE DIFFERENT THAN THE LOWER
ASSESSMENT OUT TO BE COMPLETELY
FACTUAL WITH THE COMMITTEE- THE
LETTER DOES SAY FOR ALL
CATEGORIES WE'RE NOT SAYING THAT
THERE'S NOT ROOM FOR
IMPROVEMENTS OF LESLIE- MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE CURRENT
EXEMPTION IS ELIMINATED IN THIS
IS A MAJOR ISSUE. THE COST TO
CITIES COUNTIES AND SPECIAL
DISTRICTS TO MARK THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF MILES OF NON
PRESSURIZED SEWER LINES IN NON
PRESSURIZED STORM DRAINS IT POSE
LITTLE OR NO DANGER WOULD BE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS NOW THE ONE
OF THE WITNESSES JUST MENTION
THAT THERE ARE TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF. PRESUMABLY HE MEANT SEWER
LINES BEING HIT JUST TO PUT IN
PERSPECTIVE L. A. COUNTY
SANITATION DISTRICT SERVES
EIGHTY TWO CITIES. AND FIVE AND
A HALF MILLION PEOPLE THEY HAVE
FORTY SIX HUNDRED MILES A SKINNY
SIX FOURTEEN HUNDRED MILES OF
NOT PRESSURIZE LINES SIXTY MILES
A PRESSURIZED WHICH INDEED ARE
MARKED. BUT THEY SAY THEY HAVE
ONE OR TWO HITS TO THEIR NINE
PRESSURIZE LINES A YEAR SO
THAT'S A MAJOR AGENCY THAT SAYS
A GENERALLY HAVE ONE OR TWO HITS
A YEAR SO WE THINK THE NUMBERS
QUITE LOW AND WOULD ARGUE
THEY'RE CERTAINLY NOT IN THE
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS USING. JASON I COULD
WITH ADULTS DEAN GILBERT ROBESON
SMITH ON BEHALF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SANITATION DISTRICTS
MISTER DILLON ACTUALLY JUST
MENTIONED A LOT OF THE
STATISTICS THAT THAT I WAS GOING
TO SHARE WITH YOU SO I WON'T I
WON'T BELABOR THEM BUT BUT I DID
WANT TO MAKE A POINT BASED ON
SOMETHING THAT THE PROPONENTS
SAID WHICH- THE REFERENCE WAS
MADE SEVERAL TIMES TO SEWER
COMPANIES L. A. C. S. D. AND THE
CITY IS THAT IT SERVES OUR OUR
OUR LOCAL AGENCIES WHICH MEANS
THAT. THE COST OF LOCATING AND
MARKING THOSE FOURTEEN HUNDRED
MILES OF LINES WHICH ARE MOSTLY
YOU KNOW 9295% NON PRESSURIZE
LINES ARE GONNA BE MEASURED IN
THE MILLIONS THAT'S NOT GOING TO
COME OUT OF IT A COMPANIES
PROFIT MARGIN THAT'S GONNA COME
OUT OF A LOCAL RATEPAYERS
POCKETS. M. AND YOU HAVE TO
BALANCE THAT COST AGAINST THE
POTENTIAL RISK OF ACTUALLY
STRIKING ONE OF THOSE LINES IS
MISTER DILLON LAID OUT CORRECTLY
OUR LINES TEND TO BE DEEPER THAT
WAS ACKNOWLEDGED BY THE
PROPONENTS AS WELL YOU KNOW IN
THE ONE TO TWO HITS THAT WE HAVE
A YEAR- YOU KNOW WE HAVE NO
EXPERIENCE WITH SEWAGE RUNNING
OFF OF AN EXCAVATION SITE AND
YOU KNOW AS MR DON'T SAID WE
WOULD ALSO QUESTION THIS THIS
NOTION THAT THERE ARE TEN
THOUSAND LINE HITS WHEN AGAIN
WE'RE- WE'RE RELATIVELY LARGE.
SANITATION AGENCY AND WE'RE
EXPERIENCING ONE TO TWO A YEAR-
SO AT THE END OF THE DAY MEMBERS
YOU KNOW WE UNFORTUNATELY HAVE
TO BE OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED THIS
BILL UNLESS THEEXEMPTION IS
REINSTATED YOU KNOW THE RISK IT
IS HERE HAS TO BE EVALUATED
AGAINST THE POTENTIAL COSTS AND
WE THINK THE RISK IS VERY LOW
THE COST IS RELATIVELY HIGH. THE
LAST POINT I WOULD MAKE IS THAT
FOR FROM FROM LA CSTS
PERSPECTIVE THERE OTHER
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL THAT
GENERALLY SHIFT LIABILITY FROM
EXCAVATORS ON TO LOCAL PUBLIC
AGENCIES ONE EXAMPLE WOULD BE
UNDER CURRENT LAW L. A. CST HAS
THE AUTHORITY NOT TO LOCATE AND
MARK WHEN AN EXCAVATION SITE IS
NOT CLEARLY DELINEATED. THAT
MAKES SENSE IT HOULD NOT BE A
GUESSING GAME WHERE'S WORK IS
GOING TO BE PERFORMED BUT AS
THIS BILL AS WRITTEN- WE NO
LONGER HAVE THAT ABILITY WITH
THE ONUS WOULD BE. ON US TO
FOLLOW UP WITH EXCAVATORS AND
AGAIN TRY. TO MAKE OUR BEST.
ABOUT WHERE WORK IS GOING TO BE
PERFORMED. SO FOR ALL THESE
REASONS WE HAVE TO BE OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL TODAY AND- WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTING YOUR NO
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. IS THERE ANYONE ELSE IN
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED THAT
WOULD LIKE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT TESTIMONY. THING THEN
WE'LL MOVE ON TO THAT-
TELECONFERENCE LINE. MATTER
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD ASK IF
THERE IS ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO. TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
SB THIRTEEN FORTY FIVE. THANK
YOU HERE IN OPPOSITION UP AT
EIGHT THIRTEEN FORTY FIVE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AGAIN THAT IS ONE AND THEN
THEREAFTER IN OPPOSITION OF S.
E. THIRTEEN FORTY FIVE. AND MY
MOMENT WE COULD HAVE ONE LINE
THANK YOU. THIS REMINDER RERUN
OPPOSITION UP AT HE.
THIRTEEN
FORTY FIVE.
WE WILL GO LINE FIFTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU AND GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN NAME IS
THOMAS WENT THERE AND I AM
REPRESENTING REGIONAL SAND AND
WE CURRENTLY OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
THANK YOU. AND MEDICARE WE HAVE
NO FURTHER OPPOSITION QUEUE AT
THIS TIME VERY GOOD- WILL BRING
THE MATTER BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. SENATE SENATOR. WE
MADE PROGRESS IN YOUR WINNER
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- I THANK
YOU FOR THOSE LEGISLATION I'M
GONNA SUPPORT IT TODAY- BUT I'M
DOING SO WITH SOME HESITATION I
THINK SOME OF THE- CONCERNS
RAISED BY OPPONENTS I HOPE
YOU'RE CONTINUING TO WORK. WITH
AND I KNOW THE SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
WHICH IS A- A PUBLIC AGENCY THAT
YOU KNOW DOES A TERRIFIC JOB.
MANAGING THE SEWER SYSTEMS AND
THE WATER SYSTEM AND A POWER
SYSTEM IN SAN FRANCISCO I'M SURE
THOSE CONCERNS AND- AND THAT'S
AN AGENCY THAT'S VERY FOCUSED ON
ON SAFETY SO- WERE YOU. WHERE
YOU. WORK WITH THE A POINT AND
WE ARE AND IF I MAY I WOULD LIKE
TO MAKE SOME. THAT WE WOULD WORK
AND INTENDED THAT MIGHT WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT IT'S CONVEYED
CLEARLY WHAT THE INTENT OF THE
BILL IS. THE SIZE IDENTIFICATION
SO- WITH REGARDS TO THE NOTION
THAT IT'S NOT EASE A SAFETY
CONCERN WITH THE SEWER LINES I
HAVE TO BEG TO DIFFER. AS YOU
UNDERSTAND THAT IF THERE'S A
SEWAGE LEAK IF THERE'S AN
ACCIDENT THAT THAT CAN
CONTAMINATE OUR WATER SOURCES TO
AND OUR LINES TO THAT ACTUALLY
COULD CREATE A BIGGER PROBLEM
THAT AFFECTS OUR WATER. AND NOT
ONLY THAT BUT IT ALSO COULD IT
COULD AFFECT THE IMPACT THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE ACTUALLY SKV
EXPOSED THE SEWAGE WATER IT'S
ONE OF THE REASONS WHY PEOPLE
DON'T GO AROUND. AND RECOMMEND
GOING AROUND IN THE IN THE
COMPLICATIONS THAT WE HAVE WHEN
WE HAVE- DISASTERS AND YOU HAVE
ALL THE LINES ARE BROKEN IN IN
WATER IN TO DATE IN THE SWITCH
BEING CONTAMINATED THERE SO
THERE IS A SAFETY CONCERN
WITHOUT REGARD. NUMBER TWO. I
COME FROM LOCAL- AS AN LOCAL
CONTROL ADVOCATE IN SO I'M VERY
VERY SENSITIVE TO OUR LOCAL
DISTRICTS AND A SPECIAL SPECIAL.
SPECIAL DISTRICTS WITH WATER AND
SEWER OURS IT COMBINED. IN MY
OWN CITY SO I A- I A VERY
COGNISANT OF THE CONCERNS IN THE
IN THE- THE CONCERNS IN THE- IN
THE RATIONALE BEHIND WHY THEY
WOULD LIKE TO BE EXCLUDED
HOWEVER I. WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THAT THIS BILL IN THE BILL'S
INTENT IS TO JUST IDENTIFY NOT
ALL THE FOURTEEN HUNDRED.
FOURTEEN HUNDRED MILES THAT THEY
HAVE IN LINE OR PER SE IN IN
THIS PARTICULAR DISTRICT BUT
ONLY WHEN AND ASK NECESSARY WHEN
THE EXCAVATION IS HAPPENING THAT
IS THE ONLY TIME THAT THERE.
REQUIRED TO COME AND LOOK TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE THE A
DENTIST BY WHERE THE SEWER LINES
ARE. NOW WHEN THE COST THAT
WOULD NOT WE DON'T EXPECTING TO
PREEMPTIVELY AB IDENTIFY ALL OF
THE LINES SOME OF WHICH COULD BE
DIFFICULT TO IDENTIFY BECAUSE OF
THE AGE. AT THEIR BEEN AROUND
AND I GET THAT HOWEVER ONLY WHEN
AND IF NECESSARY- ACTUALLY WIN
BECAUSE IT WILL BE NECESSARY
WHEN THE EXCAVATION SO IT'S VERY
LIMITED IN SCOPE. AND WHEN IT
COMES TO THE COST IF THERE'S
EVER DAMAGE TO ANY OF THESE
LINES. THE PERSON RESPONSIBLE
ARE THE EXCAVATORS. AND THEY CAN
COST ANYWHERE DEPENDING ON THE
LEVEL OF DAMAGE AS LITTLE AS
FIFTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS THIRTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS. COULD BE MORE.
IN THE ESCALATORS HAVE TO YOU
HAVE TO PAY THAT THEY'RE THE
RESPONSIBLE THERE'S NOBODY ELSE
RESPONSIBLE EXCEPT FOR THAT. SO
WHEN IT COMES TO DOING OUR JOB
SPECIALLY IF- THE WATER DISTRICT
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR THEIR FOR
MAINTAINING AND LOOKING AFTER
THEIR THEIR THEIR LINES. THE
SEWER DISTRICT SHOULD BE
RESPONSIBLE JUST AS MUCH- SO I
JUST WANTED TO ADDRESS THOSE
THOSE. THOSE POINTS THAT WERE
MADE EARLIER- I THINK IT ALL OF
THEM. BUT SEE SAFETY AND WHAT I
WHAT I WHAT I HEARD SENATOR
WIENER ASK IS WHETHER YOU'RE
WILLING TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION WE WILL ALWAYS
CONTINUE I AM A HUGE ADVOCATE.
YEAH I FEEL I FEEL IT'S JUST
WHATEVER I DON'T KNOW AND AGAIN
I'M AN AUTHOR TO OUR AND
DIFFERENT PEOPLE SAY DIFFERENT
THINGS BUT I JUST IT SOUNDS IT
IS MAYBE EVEN A LITTLE BIT OF A
BREAKDOWN IN COMMUNICATION I
HOPE NOT BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN WE
JUST HAD AN IN PERSON MEETING
THIS WEEK- AND IT WE WILL
CONTINUE HAVE A SAID THIS WEEK
THAT WE MET IT WAS THE LAST WEEK
WAS LAST WEEK. I'M SO WE MET IN
PERSON HAD A CONVERSATION WITH
THE STAKEHOLDERS- AND I'M A HUGE
ADVOCATE OF HAVING ALL
STAKEHOLDERS AT THE TABLE IN
ORDER TO HAVE BALANCED POLICY
AND THAT'S WHY I WANTED TO MAKE
SURE SOMETIMES NOT ALL THE
INFORMATION IS CLEARLY CONVEYED
SO THAT THIS IS WHY I FEEL IT'S
COMPLETELY IMPORTANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT I ADDRESS. THE SAFETY
PART OF IT THE LINES THAT WE'RE
NOT EXPECTING THEM TO IDENTIFY
ALL OF THE LINES BECAUSE I
UNDERSTAND THE COSTS THAT WOULD
HAVE COME ABOUT AND OF COURSE
THAT THAT COST IS TAXPAYER MONEY
SO WE WANT TO BE EFFICIENT AND
EFFECTIVE WHICH IS WHY. ONLY
WHEN AND WHEN NECESSARY THAT'S
IT THE START OF YOUR QUESTION.
IS ONGOING TO CONTINUE WORKING
ON YEAH ABSOLUTELY FOR THE BILL
TODAY IS AN IMPORTANT ISSUE
THANK YOU ABSOLUTELY. CENTER
DRESS YEAH I JUST WANT. THE
AGREED- CENTER WIENER ABOUT.
THESE ISSUES- AND IF YOU DO YOU
. IS THERE A DISK. OVER THE-
AMOUNT OF WORK THAT IT WOULD
TAKE. TO DO WHAT. THIS BILL
CALLS FOR. AND IF YOU AGREE THAT
IT'S ONLY ONE OR TWO. HITS I
DON'T KNOW THIRTY YEAR HOWEVER
BUT IT SEEMS SO MEN MINUSCULE.
IS THERE A DISAGREEMENT OVER
THAT OR ARE YOU IN AGREEMENT
OVER THAT. THAT I'M- WELL OF
COURSE IF YOU'RE TALKING TO
STAKEHOLDERS THEY'RE THEY'RE
EACH GOING TO HAVE THEIR- THEIR
OWN PERSPECTIVE. MY PERSONAL
RESEARCH AND I'LL AND I'LL LET
YOU FOLKS BOTH SPEAK ON THEIR
BEHALF. MY PERSONAL PERSPECTIVE
IS THAT. WE JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. IN THIS AND
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IT AS FAR AS
AN AUTHOR. TRYING TO BE AS FAIR
AS I CAN WITH ALL OF IT. TRY TO
BE FAIR IN- BOTH HOW THE WORK IS
EXPECTED. IN WHOSE ACCOUNTABLE.
AND IN ORDER TO BE PREEMPTIVE TO
THE COST THAT POTENTIALLY COULD
COST. BOTH TO THE DISTRICTS AS
WELL AS THE EXCAVATORS. IF WE
ALL DO OUR JOB CORRECTLY AND IF
WE ALL ARE TRANSPARENT IF ART
DISTRICTS ARE DOING THEIR JOB.
IF THE EXCAVATORS ARE DOING
THEIR JOB. THEN THERE'S LESS
COST ONE TO THE TAXPAYERS NUMBER
TWO TO THE- TO THE TO THE
ESCALATORS IN THE COMPANIES
THEMSELVES. YEAH EVERYBODY IS
JUST DOING THEIR OWN JOB. IN
BRINGING THAT TOGETHER BUT I AM
COGNISANT. AND I WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT IT'S CLEAR. THAT IT'S NOT.
EXPECTED IN THI BILL THAT.
EVERYTHING IS IDENTIFIED. ONLY
WHEN. THE EXCAVATION IS
HAPPENING IN THAT PARTICULAR
AREA THAT'S IT AND I APPRECIATE
THAT. ARE YOU KNOW LAST YEAR I
HAD A BILL ABOUT MAKING IT
SAFER. FOR THE UTILITY WORKERS.
WHO WHO. IN ONE CASE WAS SON
KILLED. OFF BUT THAT WAS YOU
KNOW- GAS. UP SO THAT THE- I
KNOW I UNDERSTAND THE- HIBIGGER
DANGER. OF BIGGER A SAFETY
ISSUES AND I'M TO SEE THAT THE
OPERATING. ARE SUPPORT OF ANY
ENGAGE BUT IF THERE'S ANYTHING
ELSE THAT- CAN BE SAID ABOUT YOU
KNOW THIS THIS ISSUE OF. THE
LEVEL OF A- DANGER. THAT EXISTS
OUT THERE CAN BE HELPFUL. VERY
GOOD I'M IT THIS IS NOT
NECESSARY I THINK WE THINK
PEOPLE ARE ARE MOVING TOWARDS- A
SUPPORT ON THE BILL AND THE KEY
HERE IS THAT SHE'LL CONTINUE TO
HAVE CONVERSATIONS WITH WITH THE
OPPOSITION SO THAT THERE'S A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF YOU KNOW
WHAT AMENDS MIGHT BE NECESSARY
OR OR NOT IT'S A IT'S REALLY UP
TO THE AUTHOR- DO WE HAVE A
MOTION ON. THE BILL SENATOR
NIELSEN. AND I THOUGHT I HEARD
YOU. MOVE THE BILL- YOU MAY
CONCLUDE. THIS BILL WILL
INCREASE THE SAFETY OF
EXCAVATORS ARE WHO NEED TO DIG
IN AREAS THAT CONTAINS OF
SERVICE INSTALLATIONS IN JUST A
LITTLE BIT MORE OF
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
FOR EVERYONE THANK YOU I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT
FIRST AMEND AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL SENATOR
CAMBIADO I FELT BIRO HI SENATOR
NIELSEN. NIELSEN AYE SENATOR
DRAWS OUT HI DURAZO HI SENATOR
HERTZBERG. SENATOR ALL RIGHT
WIENER I. THE VOTE IS FORTY ZERO
THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- HAVE ONE MORE BILL IF I
COULD JUST HAVE A MINUTE.
ALL.
MADAM CHAIR HAS S. B. 13492%
PROCEED AS YOU WILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR. GIVE ME
GREAT PLEASURE TO PRESENT S. B.
THIRTEEN FORTY NINE WHICH WOULD
CREATE A NEW STATE TAX CREDIT TO
INCENTIVIZE THE USE OF THE
FEDERAL WORK OPPORTUNITY TAX
CREDIT FIRST I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IS BEING
PROVIDED AND I WILL BE ACCEPTING
THE AMENDMENT PROPOSED IN
COMMENT FIVE ON PAGE FOUR OF THE
ANALYSIS. IN NINETEEN NINETY
FOUR THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
ENACTED A NEW LAW ESTABLISHING
THE WORK OPPORTUNITY TAX CREDIT
WHICH ALLOWS EMPLOYERS TO CLAIM
A FEDERAL TAX CREDIT IF THEY
HIRE AN INVESTED INDIVIDUALS
SEEKING TO WORK THAT HAVE
CONSISTENTLY FACE BARRIERS TO
EMPLOYMENT. THROUGH THIS FEDERAL
TAX CREDIT EMPLOYERS CAN CLAIM A
CREDIT BASED ON WAGES PAID TO
INDIVIDUALS FROM CERTAIN
TARGETED GROUPS. ELIGIBLE
SEEKERS JOBSEEKERS INCLUDE
VETERANS WITH THE SERVICE
CONNECTED DISABILITY TEMPORARY
ASSISTANCE TO NEEDY FAMILIES AND
FOOD STAMP RECIPIENTS FORMERLY
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS
INDIVIDUALS ON LONG TERM
UNEMPLOYMENT JUST TO NAME A FEW.
THROUGH THIS PROGRAM EMPLOYERS
OBTAINED CERTIFICATION TO THE
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT TO ENSURE
INDIVIDUALS HIGHER MEET THE
QUALIFICATIONS UNDER THE WORK
OPPORTUNITY TAX CREDIT AND
EMPLOYERS PROVIDE THIS FOR
CERTIFICATION TO THE IRS WHEN
CLAIMING THE CREDIT. IN TWENTY
TWENTY CALIFORNIA PROVIDED
CERTIFICATION FOR OVER A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY THOUSAND ELIGIBLE
EMPLOYEES FOR THE FEDERAL TAX
CREDIT BUT THE FACT OF THE
MATTER IS THE ECONOMY IS STILL
LEAVING TOO MANY PEOPLE BEHIND.
DESPITE RECOVERING UNEMPLOYMENT
RATES. MANY INDIVIDUALS FACE
SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS TO
EMPLOYMENT AND STRUGGLE TO FIND
WORK AND REMAIN UNEMPLOYED.
INDIVIDUALS IMPACTED BY THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM SYSTEM
SUCH AS THOSE THAT WERE FORMERLY
INCARCERATED STILL HAVE VERY
HIGH RATES OF UNEMPLOYMENT AND
ACCORDING TO THE CENTER FOR LAW
AND SOCIAL POLICY. THE
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE FOR FORMERLY
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS IS OVER
27% WHILE FOR FORMERLY
INCARCERATED BLACK MEN IT IS
ABOVE 35% S. B. THIRTEEN FORTY
NINE WILL FURTHER INCENTIVIZE
THE USE OF THE WORK OPPORTUNITY
TAX CREDIT BY CREATING A SIMPLE
EXPANSION OF THE CURRENT FEDERAL
PROGRAM. INSTEAD OF CREATING A I
CALIFORNIA'S VERSION OF THE
PROGRAM WHICH IS
ADMINISTRATIVELY BURDENSOME AND
COSTLY FOR THAT FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD THIS BILL WILL SIMPLY
ALLOW AN EMPLOYER TO HIRE A
QUALIFIED CALIFORNIA JOB SEEKER.
TO PROVIDE THE SAME
CERTIFICATION UNDER THE FEDERAL
PROBE PROGRAM FIFTY B. IN OTHER
WORDS THEY COULD TAKE THAT
FEDERAL CERTIFICATION FROM OUR
OWN DEPARTMENT OF A OF
EMPLOYMENT AND EMPLOYMENT. TO F.
T. B. TO RECEIVE AN ADDITIONAL
ONE THOUSAND DOLLAR TAX CREDIT
AGAINST THEIR CALIFORNIA TAXES.
THIS TAX CREDIT HAS A PROVEN
TRACK RECORD OF HELPING TO
EMPLOY PEOPLE WHO HAVE FACED A
STARK BARRIERS TO CAREER
STABILITY AND HELP LIFT
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES OUT OF
POVERTY. WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN FORTY
NINE. AND TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS IS ADAM KAY WHO'S THE
MANAGING DIRECTOR OF THE REDWOOD
CAPITAL INVESTMENTS AND STEVE
ABBOTT POLICY LEAD WITH GUSTO.
THE RECOVERY- HAVE MISTER KANE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PROCEED. YEAH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND THANK YOU FOR
THIS BILL AS WELL AS TO YOUR
STAFF FOR ALL THEIR SUGGESTIONS
AND TECHNICAL MAINTENANCE. I'M
WITHOUT THE COMPILER WE JUST
READ WHAT THE MAXIMUM AND WE
HAVE. SEVERAL DIFFERENT TYPES OF
COMPANIES OPERATING CALIFORNIA
THAT HAVE A- A VERY COMPLETE
CENTRIC CLEANING SERVICE
COMPANIES ON THE TECHNOLOGY
SIDE. ARE THE HOME CARE SIDE AND
EVEN SOME CAR DEALERSHIPS AND
CAR DEALERSHIPS ALL OF WHICH
HAVE A BIG- SERVICE EMPLOYEE
BASE I THINK THE SENATOR
DESCRIBED THE CREDIT VERY WELL
IT'S REALLY TARGETING PEOPLE WHO
EMPLOYMENT. AND ESPECIALLY
GROUPS. HAVE BEEN HARD HIT BY
THE PANDEMIC. WE HOPE THAT IN
EXTRA TAX CREDIT ON TOP OF THE
FEDERAL TAX CREDIT WOULD HAVE.
IMPACT OF THE INCREASING THE
WORKFORCE PARTICIPATION RATE.
WHICH IS DESPERATELY NEEDED AS
WE STILL HAVE WORK FORCE
PARTICIPATION LAGGED RATES FLAT
EVEN- THE PREVENTIVA TIMES. WILL
ALSO HELP BUSINESSES WITH TO
AVOID THE SIGNIFICANT WAGE
INFLATION WHICH IS A DESIRABLE
OUTCOME OF THIS ECONOMY BUT IT
COMES ON THE HEELS OF- A COUPLE
OF VERY BAD YEARS YOUR
BUSINESSES AND WE WANT TO
CONTINUE TO SEE. WE JUST GO UP
AND THIS WILL HELP WITH THAT.
AND FINALLY AT THE MENTIONED.
THIS IS REALLY A STATE AND
FEDERAL PARTNERSHIP AT THIS AT
AT CURRENTLY BECAUSE- THE STATE
CERTIFY THE ELIGIBILITY AND HAS
ALL THE DATA AND THEN WE TAKE
THAT THAT INFORMATION WAS SENT
TO THE IRS. IF YOU HAD A OR
STATUS A CREDIT ON TOP OF THE
FEDERAL CREDIT IT'S VERY
EFFICIENT FOR THE STATE TO
ADMINISTER. BUT JUST AS
IMPORTANT IT'S VERY EFFICIENT
EASY UNDERSTAND PER COMPLAINERS
WHO ARE HIRING THE SOCIAL WANT
TO HIDE SPOKE TO UNDERSTAND
INSTEAD WE WOULD EXPECT. WIDER
PARTICIPATION THAN OTHER EFFORTS
LIKE THIS IN THE PAST WHERE
THERE. WAS SORT OF MORE COMPLEX
CREDITS. MISTER MANAGEMENT. IS
NUMBER ONE STATE FOR WORK
OPPORTUNITY TAX CREDIT IN THE
COUNTRY AND IS NUMBER ONE
SPECIFIC CATEGORIES INCLUDING.
APPLICABLES RECIPIENTS OF CANADA
AND THE LONG TERM UNEMPLOYED.
IT'S FISCAL IMPACT OBVIOUSLY
PROTECT TAX RATE HAS A YOU KNOW
A REVENUE IMPACT BUT OBVIOUSLY
WE'RE TAKING. PEOPLE OUT OF THE
STATE PROGRAMS OFF OF
UNEMPLOYMENT INTO THE WORKFORCE
ONE WOULD EXPECT THAT TO GROW
THE ECONOMY INCREASE REVENUES.
FINALLY I WOULD NOTE THAT WIDE
COALITION OF MANY MANY
ORGANIZATIONS THAT SUPPORT THIS
SIMPLE PROGRAM THAT TARGETS
IMPORTANT GROUPS FOR SOCIAL
JUSTICE PURPOSES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. WE HAVE ANOTHER
WITNESS THE NEW STEVE ABBOTT.
GARY YES YES. OKAY AT THANK YOU
MEASURE ON THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR ALLOWING ME TO
TESTIFY TODAY MY NAME IS STEVE
ABIT NINE PUBLIC POLICY MEET
ACOSTA A PEOPLE PLATFORM
EMPOWERS SMALL TO MEDIUM SIZED
BUSINESSES AND WE ARE PROUD TO
LEND OUR SUPPORT FOR SB THIRTEEN
FORTY NINE AND ALL THAT WOULD
CREATE A WORK OPPORTUNITY TAX
CREDIT FOR CALIFORNIA. I GOT
THAT WE ENABLE SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS TO EASILY PAY EMPLOYEES
AND CONTRACTORS REMIT TAXES THEY
COMPLY WITH LEGAL OBLIGATION TO
KEEP ACCURATE RECORDS WATERBODY
PAYROLL HUMAN RESOURCES HEALTH
BENEFITS AND FINANCIAL HEALTH
BENEFITS OPPORTUNITY THOUSAND
SMALL BUSINESSES MILLIONS OF
EMPLOYEES ACROSS THE COUNTRY IN
CALIFORNIA WE ARE PROUD TO SERVE
OVER FIFTY THOUSAND SMALL
BUSINESSES IN ADDITION SAN
FRANCISCO WITH THEIR HOME BASE
OUR MISSION I GOT GO TO BUILD A
WORLD WORKING HOURS A BETTER
LIFE WE BELIEVE BUSINESS AND
WORK ARE ALL ABOUT PEOPLE
EVERYTHING THE BUSINESS IS MADE
POSSIBLE BY PEOPLE AND GOT TO
GET FROM THE SENATE THAT
RELATIONSHIP. THIS IS WHAT WE
CALL OUR PRODUCT THE PEOPLE
PLATFORM COMPANY THERE TO KEY
STAKEHOLDERS ARE THE EMPLOYEE
AND THE EMPLOYER WE PARTNER WITH
BOTH OF THEM AND CARE ABOUT BOTH
THEIR JOURNEYS AS WELL AS THEIR
EMPLOYER. EMPLOYEE RELATIONSHIP
. INEQUITY THAT. BY THE PANDA WE
INFER. THE NEED FOR. I DEL
COUNTY. INTANGIBLE AROUND
REPRESENTS. INCLUSION SOCIAL IN
. IN EQUITY. THE START THE I
INITIALLY WE CALL. ARRIVED
PRINCIPLES ARE CRITICAL TO
CUSTOM MAKE. BUILD WERE WILL
WORK POWERS OF LIFE WE ARE CAN.
TO MAKE BUSINESS PRODUCT AND-
TO. WERE THAT WE ARE COURT. WELL
TO THE TO THE FIFTEEN YOU SAID
SHE TO. LABOR SHORTAGES BY
TAKINGSTRENGTHENED. IT IS AS WE
MOVE INTO THE FLAG PHASE OF
ENDEMIC THAT SEVEN DAYS SAID
THAT RESERVE OF THE LOWER
THEY'VE BEEN SINCE THE BEGINNING
OF THE PANDEMIC BEGAN AND
ALTHOUGH EMPLOYED IN CAL COULD
TO LAURA. RATE THAN THEY WERE
THIS SUMMER PETER FOR THE SMALL
THAT THERE STILL TIMES HIGHER
THAN THEY WERE QUITTING FEBRUARY
TWO TWENTY- THREE SIMPLER
SERVICE. MONTH 5% OF THE- OWNERS
HIRING SOMEONE- GREAT GET. WITH
5% THE NEED TO RAISE. TRACK
WORKERS. THE CREATION OF A
WORKER OF THE CALIFORNIA WORK
OPPORTUNITY TAX CREDIT COULD NOT
COMMIT ONE NEEDED TIME TO EAT
SMALL BUSINESSES IN RECRUITING
AND RETAINING EMPLOYEES FOR
TARGETED GROUPS. THE ADDITIONAL
ONE THOUSAND DOLLAR CREDIT- THAT
WORK OPPORTUNITY TAX CREDIT IS A
MEANINGFUL DIFFERENCES TO A
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER ALLOWING
AND INCREASE WAGES OR OFFER
ADDITIONAL BENEFITS. SUCH AS
HEALTH CARE RETIREMENT PLANS
WHICH ARE ESSENTIAL TO MAKE ANY
COMPETITORS IN COMPETITIVENESS
HI LABOR MARKET. YES THE
FANCIFUL SUPPORT OF S. B.
THIRTEEN FORTY NINE. I SAW A
COUPLE SMALL BUSINESSES AND
DISADVANTAGED REPLACED DURING
THAT DIFFICULT TIME. WE THANK
THE SPONSORING AFFORD AND FOR
YOUR COMMITMENT TO HELPING SMALL
BUSINESSES AND THEIR EMPLOYEES
WITHIN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. VERY GOOD. IN WE-
YEAH. CAN GO TO THE OPPOSITION
DO WE HAVE ANY UP WITNESSES TO
SAYS NO BUT THE OTHER HEADER-
THERE OR ONE MORE- SUPPORT
MISTER RUNNING GO AHEAD YES THAT
YOU- ARE MEMBERS OF THE CA KEVIN
PROVIDING. ENOUGH I WE'RE STRONG
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY GOOD
. THANK YOU ONCE FOR DRIVING.
ANY OPPOSITION HERE PRESENT.
SEEING NONE. MODERATOR DO WE
HAVE ANY OPPOSITION ONLINE. IN
Q. DO YOU WANT ME TO DO SUPPORT
FIRST TRUST BOARD FOR SHE IS A
STRICT OVER THAT MOST IMPORTANT
GET TO SUPPORT FIRST. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT THAT BUT HE
THIRTEEN FORTY NINE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN
ADDED ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT OF S. B. THIRTEEN FORTY
NINE. AND ONE MOMENT FOR OUR-
PRESSURES FOR SUPPORT. REMINDER
TO WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
THIRTEEN FORTY NINE. WITHOUT THE
LINE SIXTY SIX YOUR LIGHT IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
PRESIDENT YOUNG FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
HERE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
OPERATOR ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES AND Q. NEXT WATER LINE
IS SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MORE IN A
NUMBER AT THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION AWARE IN SUPPORT OF-
SB THIRTEEN FORTY DOLLARS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WE
HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORT IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU CAN WITH THE NOW OPERATOR GO
TO ANYONE AND Q. AND OPPOSITION. THANK YOU IT HERE IN
OPPOSITION OF AT THE THIRTEEN
FORTY NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS AN
OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. HEY MISTER I SEE NO
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
. VERY GOOD. THAT SAID THEN VIA
HAVE ANY ANY OTHER WITNESS NO
MORE IN Q. NUMBER HERE. A LITTLE
BIT OF OKAY LET EVERYBODY GO
PARDON I REQUEST OFF OKAY. WE
HAVE A MOTION DO PASS. AND
OFFENDER RUSSELL YEAH I'M
KNOWING THE SENATORS HISTORY OF
CARING OF FOR OUR SPECIAL
AIRPORT COMMUNITIES ARE LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES- I THINK I
HAVE A AN IDEA OF WHY YOU'RE
MOVING THIS MONTH TO GET PEOPLE
WHO ARE EVEN WORSE SITUATION OF
THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK SO I.
TOTALLY SUPPORTER OF THAT- LAST
YEAR WHEN I OFTEN WAS ABLE TO
MOVE OF THE BILL TO HELP WELL
LEGISLATION OR FUNDING TO HELP
HOME PREVIOUSLY HOMELESS.
INDIVIDUALS I LEARNED A LITTLE
BIT MORE ABOUT IT- I THINK I
WOULD I WOULD JUST URGE YOU TO.
LOOK FOR WAYS IN WHICH THOSE
INDIVIDUALS- THAT GET THE JOBS
AND THE EMPLOYERS THAT HIRE THEM
IS HOW TO HELP THOSE INDIVIDUALS
GET EVEN FURTHER THAN JUST. THE
JOB WHO KNOWS FOR SIX MONTHS A
YEAR YOU KNOW HOWEVER LONG THE
ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS MIGHT HELP
THAT EMPLOYER- BECAUSE WHAT
WE'RE REALLY LOOKING FOR IS A
REAL LONG TERM. COMMITMENT TO
THESE INDIVIDUALS OTHERWISE THEY
FALL INTO THE SAME THING A CYCLE
OF THE SAME INDIVIDUALS GETTING
HIRED FOR SIX MONTHS OR A YEAR
HERE AND BLAH BLAH BLAH AND THAT
DOESN'T REALLY GIVE THE- THE
STABILITY THAT THEY'RE LOOKING
FOR- SO I JUST. URGE TO SEE HOW
WE COULD CONNECT THEM EITHER YOU
KNOW- THAT THEY BE IN THE SYSTEM
WHETHER SUPPORT SERVICES
ALREADY- WHAT WE DID WITH THE
HOMELESS WE HAD A- A 120% OF THE
MINIMUM WAGE THAT WAS JUST
SLIGHTLY MORE. TO GIVE THAT
INCENTIVE TO A TO THE EMPLOYEES
TO THE MEN AND WOMEN THEY HIRED
SO THAT'S JUST ONE PIECE AND I'M
I'M JUST CURIOUS- THE EX BELIEVE
BUSINESSES ARE EXCLUDED WHAT'S
THE SORT OF. RATIONALE FOR THE
THAT I CAN GET THE- NOT.
BUSINESSES THAT ARE SEXUALLY
ORIENTED. BUT THE A FEW OF THE
OTHER ONES I'M JUST CURIOUS. WHY
THERE IT IS THAT ARE EX YEAH IT
SAYS TEMP I GET TEMPORARY HELP-
RETAIL TRADES. FOOD SERVICES
DINNER THEATERS. BECAUSE HE
KNOWS YEAH USUALLY IT'S RELATED
TO TEST SEX AND ALCOHOL OR
DRUGS. BUT OKAY OKAY THAT
ANYTHING THAT HAS TO DO WITH
THAT. RETAIL TRADES ANYWAY WE
CAN TALK ABOUT IT SOME MORE BUT-
I WAS CURIOUS I HAD NOT SEEN
THAT BEFORE. OKAY THANK YOU YEAH
MY I THINK PART OF THE PART OF
THE REASON THAT IT SET UP THE
WAY IT IS WE JUST WANTED TO TAKE
EXACTLY WITH THE FEDS. WERE
DOING- SO T'S NOT NECESSARILY
OUR EVALUATION OF WHAT WHETHER
THOSE ARE. GOOD BUSINESSES ARE
NOT QUITE FRANKLY SOME OF THE
PEOPLE THAT MAKE THE MOST MONEY
OR BARTENDERS PEOPLE THAT WORK
IN THAT KIND OF A OF A TRADE
BUT- BUT WE JUST TOOK THE FOR.
THE FEDERAL- STRUCTURE AND SAID
LET'S LET'S ADD. TO IT AND- MAKE
IT WORK. ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS
CENTER DORADO NO COMMENTS AND
THEN- WINNER ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS WE HAVE A MOTION
THEN BEFORE US. WITH THE BLACK
TO CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
I THAT THE WHOLE POINT OF THIS
IS REALLY TO INCREASE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR- ARE PEOPLE WHO
WANT TO WORK TO WORK- AND IF
THERE'S ONE THING THAT THAT- I
HAVE LEARNED ABOUT THE QUALITY
OF WORK OR THE IMPORTANCE OF
WORKING IS THAT WE TAKE OUR
SELF. OUR SENSE OF SELF UP FROM
THE ABILITY BE ABLE TO WORK TO
BE ABLE TO SUPPORT FOR OUR
FAMILIES TO BE ABLE TO- US
SUPPORT OUR- OUR COMMUNITIES AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IS ALL
ABOUT NIGHT. RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. COMMEND YOU
FOR THE- ENTHUSIASM ABOUT IT IS
IT'S ABOUT OPPORTUNITY. ALL
RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION. WE HAVE
A CLOSE WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR CAFIERO
CABALLERO HIS SENATOR NIELSEN
AYE NIELSEN AYE SENATOR DORADO
DORADO HIS SENATOR HERTZBERG.
SENATOR WIENER. WIENER HI. AND
FOR ALL OTHER CALL ON HERTZBERG
WILL COME BACK NO HE'S AND HE'S
NOT COMING BACK THEN WE CAN. IS
FOUR ZERO KNOWS THE MEASURE
PASSES. THANK YOU SO MUCH
EVERYBODY- WE HAVE SOME BILLS
THAT ARE ON CALL. SO WE'LL GO
THROUGH THE ON CALL LIST
OTHERWISE THANK YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHO WERE HERE
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION TODAY- AND. ONE I. BUT.
SEVEN
PRESIDENT. OKAY. WE'RE GONNA
CALL THE BILLS THAT WE PLACED ON
CALL THE FIRST IS ITEM NUMBER
TWO S. B. EIGHT SIXTY. SENATOR
WIENER. SIX EIGHT SIXTY FIVE
WIENER HI. THAT BILL IT A PAST
FIVE TWO ZERO. NOW WE'RE MOVING
ON TO. I AM NUMBER FIVE SB NINE
NINETY ONE I SENATOR NEWMAN.
SENATOR WIENER. WIENER HI THAT
BILL. THAT'S NEWMAN. THAT BILL
IS OUT FIVE ZERO. MOVING ON TO.
I AM NUMBER SEVEN S. B. ELEVEN
SEVENTY ONE BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO. SENATOR WIENER.
ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE ELEVEN I'M
SORRY ELEVEN SEVENTY SEVEN FIVE
WIENER HI THAT BILL IS OUT FIVE
TWO ZERO. AND THEN SENATOR ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN SB EIGHT NINETY
ONE BY SENATOR HERTZBERG.
SENATOR WIENER WIENER HI THAT
BILL IS OUT FIVE. TWO ZERO. AND
THE LAST ONE IS ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE. S. B. NINE THIRTY EIGHT
BY CENTER HERTZBERG SENATOR
WIENER WIENER AYE AYE BILL IS AT
FIVE TWO ZERO. THANK YOU THANK
YOU TO ALL OF THE INDIVIDUALS
THAT PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU WERE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORD. THANK YOU AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION
THANK THANK YOU TO EVERYONE FOR
YOUR PATIENCE AND COOPERATION WE
HAVE CONCLUDED THE AGENDA AND
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE IS
ADJOURNED. WELL.